[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nos invités
dates ci dessus ph campait avec moi de
dôme plantes
cette semaine au podcast super belle
conversation avec india desjardins qui
est une auteure préférant connu pour les
aurélie laflamme qui est vraiment
plusieurs d'entre vous on lui ont
apprécié
on a parlé du succès phénoménal de cette
série lors de son succès phénoménal de
parler les parallèles qu'on pouvait
faire entre aurélie et harry potter on a
parlé de réseaux sociaux beaucoup ce que
je regarde minutes
elle parlait de réseaux sociaux puis un
peu qu'est ce qui a changé aujourd'hui
avec la venue de cette technologie le
qu'est ce qui a changé pour aurélie
c'est à son époque il y avait des
réseaux sociaux
on a parlé sa relation entre public et
on a parlé du syndrome de l'imposteur
qui malgré le succès immense de ndélé
jardin c'est syndrome de l'imposteur qui
le guettent encore aujourd'hui alors
c'était très très touchant
c'est une belle conversation avec une
personne phénoménal si vous aimez le
sans-fil podcast nous plaît nous suivent
sur pétrone qui est une communauté qui
vise à nous encourager en fait peut
avoir accès à du contenu exclusif puis
comme vous allez pouvoir le constater
pendant ce podcast si vous allez pouvoir
poser vos questions aux invités
on a une question d'un aux patrons
pétrone qu' une de nos patrons paix tu n
en fait qu i qui est posée à india
durant le peu de cas de la bonne
question traîne exact donc si vous
voulez aussi aux autres avant pouvoir
poser des questions aux invités à les
voir pétrone c'est dans la dèche son la
vidéo
sinon abonnez-vous à la chaîne youtube
sans fil podcast pour être à l'affût
à chaque fois qu'on sort nouveau podcast
aussi commenter vos impressions sur la
discussion discussion très riche cette
semaine donc on aimerait se voir lire
vos commentaires ou ce que vous avez à
ajouter à cette diction le et sinon bon
podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
dia merci beaucoup d'être là pour
l'invitation
c'est vraiment un honneur de recevoir au
nom harris pré écoute ça fait longtemps
que je voulais quelqu'un que je voulais
un équilibre il n a oui les candidats
littéraire sur le podcast qui ça y est
je suis vraiment contente et la première
un one way ouais j'suis fia légende en
plus l'avantagé du québec et je passe la
main
bah ouais c'est un compliment parce que
moi c'est vraiment une idole le petit
j'ai lu tout l'été combien de fois
chaque mais j'aurais le goût des fois
mais moi je la mets à relire qui m étais
j'ai beaucoup été inspiré par son
parcours
parce que quand même moi j'ai envoyé mes
livres mon premier manuscrit dans des
maisons d'édition eh ben j'ai reçu
beaucoup beaucoup de refus piges
j'avais lu l'histoire de ce qu'est elle
aussi alors reçu énormément de refus
puis à continuer de persévérer tous ceux
qui sait ça m'inspirait on dirait que
des fois je me dis ah ben je veux je
veux essayer une ont dressé une autre
puis on dirait que son histoire
m'inspire ips que j'ai trouvé could elle
aussi c'est que allait pas quoi le
sortir et les harry potter à leur
redonner à pleinement le goût de
riverains qui je me demande
à cette époque là il me semble que on
parlait beaucoup que les gens lisaient -
tout simple il y avait erré vraiment
plein de jeunes qui avaient commencé à
lire harry potter pas qu'elle ait
vraiment remis la lecture ogunjobi j'ai
vraiment l'impression qu'ils auront une
chimère exemple de s'alimenter moi je me
suis un dry toujours caché aux primaires
élevé une stagiaire dans la classe qui
qui prennent une partie la période pour
nous faire la lecture de harry potter tu
dis on je connaissais possible c'était
dans les petits y avait eu seulement
quelques tomes qui était sorti plein
oedipe le chalet cet homme est un bon
jeu savoir qu'est ce qui va se passer
avec les flamands j'avais des parents
puissent marcher livre j'en sais lire ce
que j'ai lu le premier belge et les
deuxième troisième
je pense que c'était rendu le à l'époque
lui après ce que j'ai lu tous les livres
fur et à mesure qu'ils sortent et qui
est factice une flamme qui était allumée
la part cette stagiaire le kindle hier
pas tant pis par harry potter du goût de
la lecture le carré tel jamais germain
et oui il ya quelque chose que il ya
quelque chose qu'on peut dire sur elle
aussi séquelles ses livres et une
profondeur elle avait quelque chose à
dire
elle avait été à l'avant un message au
niveau 2 et de l'identité comme harry
potter c'est son identité et qui lui est
bon et du méchant
puis c'est la voie qu'a choisie le
second cédant on peut dire ceux de
toutes les films fantastiques sin mais
il y avait aussi plein d'autres messages
sur le racisme m
les réseaux sociaux quand ça commençait
aussi à un moment donné elle a trouvé ce
épouvantable qui on est rendu tellement
épouvantable que tu écrives quelque
chose et qu'on te réponde
ouais puis à le parler des médias ou
sinon qu'il ya plein je trouve que
c'était harry potter puis si c'est
vraiment pas juste des livres comme ça
pour les enfants puis juste des petites
histoires non il ya vraiment un propre
honneur
mais c'est surtout le sous-texte de ses
oeuvres le qui fait la différence entre
un roman quelconque puis un
chef-d'oeuvre mois mettant non mais
écoutez moi ça hamas a marqué une
génération pis ça c'est vraiment et il
ya vraiment quelque chose là puis on
aime ce harry potter puis il y aussi de
s'assumer était comme moi la maison qui
recommande demande c'est quoi ma liste
des dix la préfecture
je vois beaucoup de jal qui sont soit
importés a nommé des classiques
moi je t'avoue que c'est pas des
classiques qui ont marqué ma vie même si
j'ai étudié en lettres piqué résolu
ouais et harry potter m'a beaucoup plus
marquée que
qu'elle écume des jours de boris c'est
un moment tellement ce que tu dis parce
que c'est sais c'est mal vu on devrait
dire cela mais justement aussi dans un
parcours en littérature quand tu parles
de stephen king comme étant une des
auteurs préférés petit fait regarder
comme c'était le dernier des comptes ccc
rohff alors qu'effectivement j'ai
beaucoup plus aimé qu jockey que
n'importe quel roman classique russe
oui c'est vrai que pilote il aimait tant
il ya déjà parce que maintenant on
dirait que quand il parle les gens
comprennent pas d'un serment au delà de
la phrase et c'est moi si je dis
maintenant mais moi harry potter mais
plus touchés que boris vian ben voyons
il s'entraîne dircab au risque du bien
c'est bon le nom s'est passé jeudi boris
vian c'est un chef-d'oeuvre ont 100
pages l'élu j'aimais me mets dans ma vie
à moi dans mon parcours de lectrices
harry potter il ya plus de il ya plus
quelque chose pour moi c'est ça plus
marqué quelque chose d'important pour
moi pour toutes sortes de raisons donc
oui c'est mal vu disputer ces temps ci
je tends communication avec une
étudiante à l'université qui fait un
travail de maîtrise sur les oreilles la
flamme et a dit qu'elle reçoit beaucoup
de jugement de ses pairs à l'université
qui parce qu'elle a décidé d'analyser
d'étudier finalement un livre qui
aurélie qui est prôné saman considérer
littéraire considéré comme d'hab de
jeunesse mais la pop exact de créatures
peu plus loin oui c'est certain qu'ils
écoutent b6
c'est sûr que c'est sûr que je la
comprends dans ce cas vie quand même taz
la trop forte de tenir à son sujet la
brume
oui quand même parce que aurélie pour
moi c'est souvent les gens qui
connaissent pas vont pas un terme à
vont pas nécessairement le juger pour ce
que c'est ils vont juste qu'ils pensent
que c'est un moment donné avec quelqu'un
qui m'avait écrit jean jé lui aurélie
agité surprise c'était moins gagnant que
je pense et ça me passe un coup au car
parce que c'est un corps humain accompli
mais c'est en même temps un conflit
[Rires]
c'est bon parce que au québec
globalement je trouve qu'ils ont de la
difficulté avec avec le succès puisqu'il
devient ce qui devient populaire il ya
automatiquement à une levée contre ce
cette popularité le puits puis souvent
le monde juge comme tu dis sans voir
sans savoir qu'est ce qu'ils jugent être
allé à l'essence même combien de monde
présent l'exemple des livres mais
combien de mon nom on juge 'twilight'
sans l'avoir lu
oui comme une personne non j'ai fait ça
mais moi je les jugeais adrets lamoly
mais c'est quand même personne prenne
une position par rapport à quelque chose
je pense qu'il faut respecter le succès
populaire
c'est même souhaitons les grands
critiques vont pas bondées - c'est
peut-être pas de là le chp à pôle emploi
mais en général quelque chose ce n'était
pas de la grande littérature c'est ptet
pas de la grande musique ou rêveurs mais
crime si un succès populaire ça touche
du monde mais ils doivent quelque chose
là dedans
peut-être que les critiques étaient
peut-être pas le public cip qui ne
s'adressait pas à lui mais il ya des
gens qui s'adressent que ça touche que
ça intéresse pis cela dit les critiques
envers au rayon toujours été non
toujours été pas mal bonne pas que ce
sujet j'ai été chanceuse là dessus mais
tu sais plus des fois tu d'autres
personnes qui le souhaitent d'autres
personnes qui leur ont pas critique et
miquelon pollue parce que les mutuelles
m'a heureusement les critiques lise mois
cinquante et un critique toi aussi la
tâche de juger pour pour ce que l'oeuvre
et tu peux pas avoir les mêmes critères
pour de la littérature jeunesse de la
nature propre adolescents puis la
littérature je peux romanesque et
romantique le titre poliment les mêmes
bases notamment optimisme et ont su en
parallèle avec la musique qui est plus
mon domaine team et on tend son
prat-mary 1000 t moi personnellement le
style de musique les paroles viennent
pas me chercher pour la musique que
j'écoute pour le bon plaisir mais je
respecte leurs six pitié je respecte le
fait qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
savent que ça touche puis alain un
succès immense et fréquemment des
tumultes bas est parfaite pour moi mais
exactement qui est une super bonne foi
mais je balise mari mais c'est de la
merde ça me touche pas donc c'est de la
marque ballon piqué si quelqu'un décide
de l'étudiant à l'université ben coup
j'ai loupé de l'approfondissement du
show que les lits you lie le masseur à
faire une analyse super valide puisse
pas intéressant il y en a déjà une qui
était fait même moi si je lisais plus
tard j'apprenais démarré à l'analyse est
aussi comme le succès petits pas calé à
faisait une analyse aussi de moi je dis
moi des choses qui ont toujours été
instinctive ou pis l'homme a été
analysée donc stay away j'ai tout fait
sage et j'ai voulu dire ce donc c'est
intéressant pour moi de les métis qui a
toujours été intéressant aussi pour moi
c'est de comparer maintenant comment on
va comparer une oeuvre mettons justement
par sa couverture et maintenant tu fais
quelque chose qui
une couverture pour un lac avec un
soleil couchant déjà partants le tuer
ceci que c'est comme si sadi petit un
livre profond une couverture puis mai
six tonnes
une fille cola de bonne humeur puisque
la couverture et colorée la baisse c'est
sûr que c'est quétaine mais si c'est une
oeuvre que comme avec une couverture qui
est plus associé à quelque chose de
masculin ça devient universelle chaque
mois il ya toujours eu cette réflexion
là aussi de m'assumer d'en faire quelque
chose parce qu'à l'époque où et sortir
élitiste et beaucoup justement les qui
avait suivi harry potter qui était très
populaire donc c'est un univers
fantastique un héros masculin qui moi
juste arrivé avec une héroïne féminine
dans le quotidien
donc c'est sûr que c'était pas des
points récemment ski pognait à cette
époque l'unpi le succès a été inattendue
mèche quand même fier même si mettons y
en a qui peuvent penser que les
couvertures annonce autre chose
n'importe quoi
quand même vraiment fier d'avoir choisi
ses couvertures le parce que moi je
talent et avec mon goût de quand j'étais
ado quand j'ai demandé à l'illustratrice
de ce que je voulais comme couverture
elle a fait exactement ce que je voulais
puis moi je sais que à cet âge là
j'aurais été portés d'aller vers un
livre comme ceux qui avec ce que j'avais
envie de transmettre aux ados mais
j'avais envie aussi de les attirer avec
quelque chose qui concordait avec ce que
moi mort et a tiré
mais moi tu vois quelqu'un tu me dis ça
je trouve pas qu'il ya péril la flandre
perd pas ton cd mais traitement au
brésil nautique est à lèvres la magie
d'harry potter histoire d'un ego qui
rentrent au secondaire jusqu'à son bal
des finissants
avec la magie qui sont exacts mais s'ils
passent à travers les étapes des trains
délaissant le premier amour pitt soutif
accueille la plainte parallèle à faire
quand je faisais tout un sujet
j'ai voulu créer c'est dans ce sens le
touriste est totale et les héros qui se
bat contre les monstres et les dragons
ont pu moi j'ai voulu créer dans la
vraie vie une héroïne qui se bat contre
les monstres et les dragons mais de la
vraie vie c'est quoi les monstres et les
dragons de la vraie vie ce centre c'est
ton prof de maths qui tout assaut de
pete des démons aussi c'est que dans la
vraie vie mais temps aurélie elle aa
doit faire face le deuil de son père
d'escaladé calais des démons puis - kg
quand j'ai commencé à écrire aurélie la
première phrase c'est parfois je me sens
seuls dans l'univers
la dernière phrase du premier tombe
c'est je me sens bien ici
qui pour moi c'est tout le cheminement
de quelqu'un que peut-être effleuré
l'idée de la mort parce que sont pas les
morts l'ol à ce sens comme une
extraterrestre place magie ne sont pas
et sur notre planète qui est dit mais
moi je serai peut-être mieux sur ce fait
pour moi il ya tout un il ya tout un
questionnement intérieur de quelqu'un
qui choisit la vie que quand tu choisis
la vie finalement choisi pour le moment
choisi pour la mort m choisi que la vie
a vient avec un lot d'obstacles que ces
obstacles urbains
tu peux les traversées d'une certaine
façon et moi c'est comme si j'ai voulu
tenir la main parce que moi j'ai trouvé
ce jour-là de l'essence mais n'y trouver
que c'est une période difficile qui est
mitigé de vie normal j'étais vraiment
une ado normal mais j'ai trouvé ça
difficile que je voulais aller vers une
ado normal mais qui trouve ça difficile
aussi des fois puis peut-être donné à
travers une histoire drôle à travers une
histoire sympathique à travers une
histoire divertissante peut-être de
donner des outils pour traverser surtout
se sentir et je me sens comme une
extraterrestre mais c'est correct d'été
c'est correct des différences c'est
correct d'avoir ses propres est passé
c'est correct d'être gaffeur c'est
correct d'être un parfait
donc c'est tout ce que je voulais
avec ce samedi on attaque de front la
question du suicide pizza
voilà ça aurait pu être ça aurait pu
être ce langlois mais il y en a qui le
font très bien puis moi je voulais je
voulais le prendre de façon ou c'est
évoqué mais que c'est pas dit comme tel
puisque de toute façon je pense que
quand tu choisis la vie
bc c'est je sais pas si ces baisses est
plus lumineux si certains qui il ya
tellement plus avoir de deux jeunes
filles jeunes hommes qui sont reconnus
dans sur le moi je viens d'une famille
où est-ce qu'ils avaient trois fois plus
que moi il y aurait la flamme était
partout maison il ya du avoir vraiment
beaucoup de monde qui qui sont reconnus
dans ce passage là parce que du monde
qui devait sentir un petit peu laissé de
côté par là les histoires qui avait
jusque là fait déjà des adolescents
normaux qui trouvais ça difficile mais
qui qui se reconnaissaient pas dans dans
toutes les autres histoires que mais
comme on parlait l'autre fois du on
parle tantôt du temps d'alexandre ou
est-ce que ça c'est un jeune adolescent
qui équivalent à celui mis mes piles son
histoire est extrêmement intéressant
mais si toi tu pas de problème
toutefois de rien d'extrême et tu vis
les petites affaires de la vie qui sont
qui sont plates mission c'est que si tu
peux être au bord du site n'est pas le
cas simple c'est ça c'est juste qu'ils
arrivent qui sont plates mais qu'ils
sont plus forts que j'explique vie être
un adolescent normal oui c'est ça qui
des fois bien les histoires et entre moi
ce que je trouvais sais c'est que oui on
pouvait aller dans le drame
on pourrait les notes c'est comme castex
des histoires de filles c'est tout a
super ciel devant la fille d'yves
espagne et le groupe populaire
galipeau ce match mais à trappes
disparaît au x5 j'ai vraiment écrit en
revanche a souri finale masse a spoilé
double plus populaire de l'école se
trouve tellement comme à trouve que ça
rien à voir avec halo pas d'affinités
pierre fait comme à et regarde moi est
dans le gagne populaire j'ai bien dit
mes amis je me reconnais plus piété à
sfax et comme le le contraire les
voyants j'ai pu aujourd'hui c'est grâce
à sa touche à peine autre thème de
thèmes aussi comme c'est des personnages
homosexuels peut-être important pour moi
piste est super important pour moi de
les mettre dans un contexte où c'était
juste normal il ya pas s'il ya un coming
out mais que c'est pas nécessairement un
coming-out non plus tu sais pas et je
voulais que ça se passe bien que j'avais
j'avais fait une entrevue avec avec 1go
pour y demander ça avait été comme en
lui son coming out et tous ceux et puis
lui savait super bien été faxée su que
je voulais intégrer dans l'histoire pour
que ce soit juste normal qu'il ya un
personnage homosexuel dans l'histoire
mais que sa surface pour une carte soit
pas le gros dos il
oui c'est ce que lui tout le monde sait
le monde l'acceptent comme ça parce que
je me dis des fois c'est correct de
montrer langue ou la personne à travers
des obstacles mais c'est qu'il y en a
d'autres comme ça c'est parfait moi je
voulais juste le faire différent dans ce
sens que quelqu'un 10e
pis durée et mettons aubin c'est normal
c'est possible que ce soit la gauche
c'est vraiment quand j'ai fait quand
j'ai sorti le film le deuxième film
d'orly il ya deux frenchies de goût dans
le film c'était super important pour moi
pis ça fait que le film a été censuré
dans quelques pays d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
le premier film
le frêne j'étais trop long pour l'italie
hu ji yai ont coupé la scène de french a
peut-être trois corps alors que moi et
ma les films d'amour les jeunes du
québec
[Rires]
mais où est donc deux french en deux
groupes pour moi c'était super important
c'est un film jeunesse je me disais puis
je veux que ce soit jean legault y est
dans un parti on le voit dans un coin
french avec un gosse c'est bien normal
c'est une personne sous l'absolu ça
soulève ce petit manège cher quand je
présentais le film et avait une petite
fille de 11 ans qui m'avait dit pourquoi
de gosse en brasse c'est dégueulasse
le j'avais dit mais pourquoi tu trouve
ça dégueulasse tu trouves ce autant
dégueulasse que faye et goody trouve ce
que j avais posé des questions on avait
une discussion puis pour moi c'était
important de répondre à ces questions là
puis justement pour pourquoi le m c'est
justement pour ces questions là pour
montrer que pour montrer la normalité
que ça se passe comment ces bons qui m
c'est une question que je laisse reposer
parce que scénarisé toi même un ton
oeuvre act loi pour le cinéma dont
adapté dont on oeuvre en fait est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui s'est fait
naturellement
pour toi parce que quand tu l'écris vais
jouer ses spécifications à ce que quand
tu l'écrivait tu avais en tête des
des images quand c'est à juste pu mettre
sur un scénario non moins quand
j'écrivais livre je l'écrivais vraiment
pour un livre t pour mon rêve c'était
vraiment de voir un jour mon livre sur
les tablettes des librairies c'était
vraiment mon rêve je me disais et si un
jour je me rends bien marché
oui quelques livres et saint geours je
me rate mon livre dans une vitrine qui
va mourir sur place
tu vois plusieurs fois sa seule pour moi
là que mon livre soit dans la vitrine ce
serait le top du top
pis si des fois mettons andrée carnac
qui sait des fois j'en ai croisé à
travers les années dans les salons du
livre puis que le disait haut et c'est
j'écris un livre en train d'écrire un
livre comment on fait pour que ça
devienne un film moi je n'ai jamais
pensé à ce moment je voulais écrire un
livre
c'est ce qui est important c'est que ce
soit un livre la première fois des
producteurs m'ont rencontré j'ai j'ai
dit non et j'ai pas sauter là dessus
parce que pour moi ce qui est important
c'est de respecter
est ce que je veux dire avec le
personnage maintenant est ce que j'ai
réussi c'est sûr qu'avec le recul je
vois des erreurs que j'ai faites si
j'étais dans mes premiers balbutiements
de scénario mais mais je trouve je suis
quand même fier parce que je me suis
respecte donc pour moi ça n'a pas été un
oui d'emblée mais quand est venu le
temps de scénariser oui je voulais que
ce soit moi parce que moi c'était
important pour moi d'être gardien d'un
peu de temps j'avais déjà j'avais déjà
un lien avec les lecteurs lectrices qui
j'avais j'avais quelque chose
d'important pour moi à dire tous les
peaux claires soient dénaturés au tour
précédent comprises
donc première affaire le premier film
j'allais coscénarisé avec le réalisateur
et puis le deuxième film je les analyse
et tout ce qui
puis c'était pas nécessairement mon
métier mais en même temps je pense que
dans l'écriture tapera tu apprends par
l'expérience apprend en lisant des
livres que j'ai lu des livres de
scénarisation parce que tu lui des
scénarios j'ai lu des scénarios et betty
je travaillais déjà un peu avec mon ex
mans du réfectoire tiki qui lui m'a
appris beaucoup au niveau de la
scénarisation piscine il ya été là pour
m'épauler aussi
donc j'ai appris beaucoup pied
comme jeudi le premier c'était ma
première expérience le deuxième c'est ma
deuxième expérience d'environ soleil or
à chaque puits c'est sûr puis c'est sûr
que maintenant je regarde les films j'en
suis fier je suis vraiment viable je
suis fier quand les parents les familles
viennent me voir dans les salons du lait
pour mesures qui ont réécouté puis qu'il
irait écoute tout le temps c'est parce
que je me dis ah ben si c'est un film
ces genres de films moi je voulais
écrire le genre de film que j'aime quand
j'étais jeune
puis finalement c'est ce que c'est ce
que ça fait parce que moi j'ai mes
soirées écouter des films est métisse tu
me demandes que ce préférence le film
que le livre c'est sûr que ces livres
parce que les vives c'est tout mon
propos complet du lot tandis que le film
fou qui met déjà couillon donc c'est
sauf que le personnage a lome - la
nostalgie que les mon personnage n'en
livre on voit moins ses réflexions aussi
sur la vie tout ça parce que c'est plus
dépendance aux têtes on est à
l'extérieur
oui c'est ça donc c'est ce qui est des
fois je me dis quitté ça m'arrive défaut
d'avoir regardé le film parce que je
pense à tes les hutus puis je me dis
artiges j'aurais peut-être mais sur un
câble de rajouter ce peut-être que oui
j'ai des limites en tant que scénariste
parce que c'est peut-être pas mon
premier gala j'ai plus de facilité à
raconter une histoire en romains puis
mais là après ce bon les fêtes sur le
difficile de choisir qu'est-ce qui fait
la cote pour le problème aussi parce
qu'on s'entend qui est un scénario
simple concise puis pas que
justement c'est bon mais on est obligé
de laisser son motoriste 1,4 j'ai dû
faire mon deuil petit le deuxième film
est basé sur les livres 7 et 8 mai livre
vii évitant tout cela fait mille pages
un scénario ça fait 95 cents pages donc
c'est sûr le que des affaires qui sont
enlevé la da qui mais oui c'est
difficile phase ii et le pied après
semaine c'est sûr qu'un réalisateur qui
embarque sa propre vision vous eu des
fautes et dans une réunion de production
plus les gens sont comme oui mais
aurélie réagir et peu comme ce que ça
dit avec aurélie alors pittarelli bien
je pense âge elle aime tellement
si on est devenus très amis ça a été ça
a été difficile trop trouvé ce se
trouvait la comédienne pour le jouer
pour toutes sortes de raisons tu fais
partie du processus de casting
au début je voulais pas parce que je me
disais parce qu'ils y ont décidé la
production d'aller 1 on a passé un
casting sauvage le de demander à la
pause juste des comédiens non
professionnels
donc je me disais moi je peux pas
choisir parmi une de mes lectrices qui à
un moment donné je me suis rendu compte
que je n'étais pas capable de lâcher
prise par rapport à mon personnage perd
ma vision du personnage
donc pour moi c'était super important
d'avoir d'avoir vraiment quelqu'un qui a
l'air d'une girl next door parce que
c'est ce que je vous dis sur aurélie
c'est une fille normale une vie normale
que donc et puis même car on était le
aux institutions financières pour
demander de l'argent
des fois on se faisait demander mais
qu'est ce qu'elle a de spécial aurélie
dit je t'aime et justement à rien c'est
ce qui c'est ça que je veux raconter
c'est pas que c'est pas quelqu'un qui
fait une compétition de quelque chose
puis qui gagna fin c'est pas quelqu'un
qui a une passion énorme piquionne afin
de pleinement
vilks a pas de passion que qui savent
qui sait pas quoi faire envie
et moi c'est l'histoire de cette
personne l'un que je raconte avec ces
histoires c'est l'histoire de quelqu'un
que normalement c'est pas le personnage
principal du film
mais quelle heure je décide d'en faire
le personnage principal donc et ps qu
aurélie tu ressembles ou pas donc ce
weed
quand je dis souvent à me ressemblent
comme mettons des enfants peuvent être
ça veut pas dire qu'il ya des chose de
toi meilleure des choses que c'est comme
particulier à elle donc aurélie c'est
pas ma vie mais il ya beaucoup de mes
émotions que j'ai vécues à l'adolescence
puis à beaucoup de mai 2002 me travers
personnel tiko manger par des araignées
mais j'suis gaffeuse j'aime le chocolat
tiède et à faire comme ceux que j'ai mis
pour le personnage mais est beaucoup
plus capable que moi je l'étais à cette
époque lourdes c'est d'avoir de la
résilience face à face aux choses
elles sont par est décédé moi mon pari
pas décédées dont il ya plein de petites
choses comme ça et puis à le plus d'amis
que ce que j'avais à l'époque mais j'ai
écrit des saintes que moi ça m'est
arrivé mais amenés à chicane avec son
ami qui en mangent tout seul dans une
toilette à l'école tu sais moi ça m'est
déjà arrivé c'est manger seul dans une
toilette de peur que les gens voient
acte est ce la table c'est comme moins
pire de manger sa toilette que manger
deux seuls à cafétéria l'école tout le
monde voit que tu es seule petite
chicane avec connaît donc pour moi c'est
important de mettre sur écoute depuis
que j'ai écrit sur le il ya tellement
monde qui me disent que ça leur est déjà
excellent de manger du seul enjeu
toilettes eu même des filles de mon
secondaire avec qui j'allais à l'école
tandis qu'il faisait
oui piloter la n6 l'eau on avait eu je
t'écoute à tout le monde en parle tu te
faisais un peu
l'apologie de la fiction parce que parce
que justement cette question-là 2-1 ce
qu aurélie c'est toi même tu sais ce
qu'est le personnage son livre c'est toi
pis tu dis un peu que toi tu croyais
encore à la fiction et pour la fiction
thé dans un air où est-ce qu'ils ont nés
raconteront au soir bâtissons raconte
soit puis tu fais un livre si tu marques
récemment inspiré d'une histoire
mais si tu marques ce soit ou fiction ce
marxiste marx comme pour garder une
espèce de distance flou ça avant de plus
par là de la télé réalité je suis bien
placé pour le savoir
j'adore la téléréalité badauds oui
j'avais pas vu ton année mais cette
année j'ai essayé pour audi grèce ont
repris au début c'était comme je pense
on le faisait rire de façon erratique
monde chez moi puis après ça c'est
totalement laisse embarquer pourquoi
c'est le fun noir
il ya un aspect sociologique là-dedans
décidé de sisyphe est un comportement
mousse que je regarde un peu comme une
expérience
oui devoir de voir un yacht ou des
affaires que moi je fais piquer
finalement quand je le vois grossit à la
loupe
samar semble puis finalement je me dis
ah mais je devrai papilles des affiches
sur la forfaiture grade de fonctionner
de voir qu'un oeil
c'est un clin d'oeil critique parce que
sinon tu te fais juste remarquer
justement comme si c'était quand même en
la fiction mais tonique ses marques et
télé réalité tu penses que c'est la
réalité qui politicienne c'est exact
mais mes atouts pour poursuivre le la
question c'est je me dis est ce que
parce que moi je me sens comme ça que je
pense beaucoup je pense que la fiction
et le énormément de mérite tout ce que
tu écris
l'accumulation toutes les expériences
que tu voyais le fait que veut pas ce
que tu écris ça c'est toi d'une certaine
façon mais la fameuse question est-ce
que aurélie c'est toi je ne sais pas si
je sais pas ça m'intéresse moi c'est
comme en fait si les gens savent plus si
si quand quelqu'un écrit ci appelle des
ailes ou s'il n'y a pas de quelque chose
d' inventer c'est moi je certaines ok
que jk rowling il ya plein de ses
expériences personnelles ou dans harry
potter
même si ça se passe à couler oui c'est
ça je sais que beaucoup d'elle si tu
vois mon ami patrick senécal qui écrit
des affaires de moeurs
tout ça c'est des fonds sans par contre
lui puis mois ensemble qu'est ce qu'on
fait on joue à des jeux ce site est
fouillé partout c'est drôle parce qu'une
fois on revenait d'un salon du livre
celui-ci avec moi pour dévoiler gens
sont comme je suis choqué je te dis que
les gens peuvent avoir sur aurélie le
fait que une voix ensemble comme ok pour
apporter le lui ai je dit et regarde il
ya des biscuits faits au chili
[Musique]
mais moi c'est sûr que ça me trouble de
voir que on dirait que de plus en plus
les livres qui sortent cd livres et
autobiographique témoin je te donne fans
de fiction j'adore lire la fiction plus
j'espère que ça va continuer qui des
fois je me demande c'est est ce que
c'est les maisons d'édition qui approche
les gens disent et on doit écrire ta bio
ou hey c'est moi je trouve ça beaucoup
si constructif que vous ayez sortir le
livre de recettes parce que au moins
vous apporter quelque chose que ça avait
été notre amour où tout se sait ce qui
s'est passé mais je trouve ça cool parce
que au moins ça amène quelque chose qui
est constructive qui est productif qui
est intéressante qui est votre passion
en forme c'est pour l'alimentation puis
en plus
transmettez 1 1 un bon message qui pisse
non betis et sauf que les livres de
fiction dans la merde autobiographie moi
j'ai l'impression que des fois pour les
nouveaux auteurs c'est plus difficile de
faire leur place
contrairement aux auteurs établies parce
que le taux plein de personnalités
connues qui sortent leur autobiographie
par travers surtout des nouveaux auteurs
qui essaye de se faufiler dans les
médias où tous ceux qui quittent souvent
choisir entre une vedette qui sort sa
biographie versus un nouvel auteur qui
sort son premier roman qui est peu
inspiré de lui
c'est ce que moi c'est un questionnement
pour moi que j'ai par rapport à mon
milieu littéraire j'ai pas de réponse
j'ai pas non plus de jugement j'ai juste
des questionnements sur qu'est-ce que
c'est en train de devenir tout se fait
dans un petit marché comme le québec
comment on pourrait essayer de faire
cohabiter tout se passe que est-ce que
tu as lu le plongeur
j'ai commencé mais moi j'ai ok j'ai un
déficit d'attention je dis pas que je
leur dise livre et non c'est que je
commence une page pileux
je me signe pu effectuer recommence
c'est long c'est laborieux il faut que
je sois en vacances
le livre est très drôle dis moi aussi
quand je t'ai en écriture
c'est pire donc mettons j'écris la
journée la presse aussi je lis je pense
à plus mon livre que ce qu'il
s'entraînerait faut que j'attende d'être
en vacances donc mais j'ai commencé
pitié c'est quelqu'un que beaucoup de
talent kiwi est allé dans l'auto fiction
mais y est allé dans l'auto fiction avec
un style avec je pense que ça c'est un
bon hybride entre les choses qu'on parle
parce que son livre est ancré dans le
réel
sûr que quand lui en parle son
personnage même s'ils s'appellent
stephan même site il y est fait tout son
parcours même si les personnages que
côtoyer celui vraie personne qui existe
et en parlent comme comme une oeuvre de
fiction
oui pt 8 parce que du moment où ou 7
ajoute des choses qui est paul inventent
des choses que tu inventes des
réflexions que te pas eu à ce moment le
veut en fait il fait juste servir de
certains souvenirs pour raconter
finalement une histoire qui extrapolez
pis c'est ça en fait à étang est un
auteur est un écrivain est un conteur
c'est de prendre quelque chose qu'il a
commencé à l'extra polypes tout ce donc
moi l'auto fiction ça me dérange pas
parce que je trouve quand même qu'il ya
un an
l'autobiographie non plus ça me dérange
pas un métier c'est sûr que je sais que
je vois moins moi en tout cas ça ça
m'intéresse moins je comprends les gens
pour qui ça les intéresse pas un moment
donné j'étais là en vacances qui je
voyais un couple à côté de moi sur le
bord de la plage kim où j'avais plein de
l'ifpi la fille elle avait plein de
livres puis legault y avait un livre
toute la semaine bio lu la biographie de
dan bigras qui sait peut-être que lui le
s'il n'y avait pas eu la biographie de
dan bigras bay aurait peut-être pour lui
c'est ce qui les intéressait donc des
fois aussi on sort plein de livres pour
aller chercher le public qui va
s'intéresser à ce que peut-être que s'il
y avait pas su bien peut-être que il y
aurait il trouverait pas quelque chose
qui l'intéresse
donc c'est pour ça que je dis que j'ai
pas de juge magi un questionnement de
comment tout se peut
peut cohabiter faut juste penser que la
fiction va pas nous amener quelque chose
de vrai l'histoire est pauvre et
anguilles - il ya une substance le kivu
qui vont te faire grandir puis que tu
que dans la vraie vie votre changer
l'europe et peut-être tout les plus
grands de la littérature en parler des
classiques tantôt c'est des heures des
fictions pour la plupart de ces parce
qu'ils talent a marqué la pensée et i2c
époque ça l'a influencé ce qui est venue
après qui pis est supprime aucun film
qu'à la fin il ya les petits petits
crédits d'iai s'était inspiré d'une
histoire vraie lipow ouais je fais pas
au mode comme la marque d'un certaine
façon ça soit vrai ou non dans le fond
ça change pas grand chose les familles
et huit bombes ce n'était pas bon
puisque j'ai vécu quelque chose c'est
comme tout bon exemple j'ai écouté
bohemian rhapsody j'ai détesté ce gpo si
toutes les banques or vu je n'ai pas
encore vu je sais quoi
poey pour meilleur film pendant l'acte 1
bonne question de ces projets
écoute pour moi c'est comme une suite de
scènes qui ont connaissance en rapport
ensemble et je me demande si j'ai fait
des recherches après pouvoir au quai
suivrait ce on dirait qu'on nous
présente la vie d'un artiste que je
trouve un peu ça respecte l'artiste mais
je comprends même pas un mot n'est
pourquoi ils sont devenus populaires
pourquoi le fait que ce soit quelqu'un
qui existe
je pense que c'est ce qui m'a intéressé
au film mais finalement j'ai trouvé que
c'était pas un bon film on me racontait
pas une bonne histoire c'est pas venu me
touchez jamais jamais jamais jamais mais
je vois pas la tronche à bout parce que
je n'ai pas vu mais je pense qu'elle est
critique souvent qui est le seul film
lost et que c'était ultra est simplifié
romance et c'était comme un client est
en studio plus tout d'un coup par magie
noire et puis c'est facile c'est comme
si non on écrire une tonne est un
travail psycho pris en 5 minutes déjà un
wok l'automobile en studio on fait des
voix puis au sité fermé recueillis
avaient une vie rocambolesque l'on est
tenté c'est tout
c'est sur cette voie là puis je sais
qu'il y avait
ciné sacha baron cohen legault qui fait
battre parce qu'il n'y aurait-il pas bon
pour le rôle parce qu'il ressemble
vraiment freddie mercury
puis si l'ego de queen qui produisent le
film tiff accès sûr que j'ai
l'impression que d'autres veulent se
mettre en scène sous un bon jour mais
tant pis lui avais dit accueillait le
scénario idiot m&i toutes les espèces
des deux parties ne peut plus l'aide de
fusil me cueillir un peu plus à l'est
tout enlever tiwa mais on vous parle de
sous on veut parler de l'histoire de
clean pouce de queen poussé comme un
collègue
on a gardé le flambeau après la mort de
fumée que huit îles telle personne c'est
pas qu'on veut le patinage mais on veut
la vérité
on veut savoir le ravin oui on veut
vraiment on veut on veut voir que ticket
qui a eu des années difficiles on veut
on veut le voir comment qui est tombé en
un mot pour la première fois avec un
goût tout ça est évacuée c'est comme
l'homme est pas vraiment le tuer à la
limite je me demandais kazma si la
personne qui avait fait le film était
homophobe qui a brûlé comme complètement
effacer tout ça autour tricks et ça
c'est peut-être justement la personne
qui veut on va on voit un peu caché ce
parce qu'on veut plaire à tout le monde
mais en voulant plaire à tout le monde
c'est la personne comme en commun le
découvert comment une époque où c'était
pas vraiment accepté comme dans une
famille avec cette religion le bref
c'est pour dire que par rapport aux
biographies
il ya des affaires qui peuvent
m'intéresser artistiquement c'est comme
étant le film sur facebook le jaune à
toi les faits sont pas nécessairement
lomé le film est excellent en compte une
bonne histoire
qui pis est l'eau ou huit points qui
prend quelque chose d'un peu près faits
réels mais tu en fais une bonne oeuvre
d'art ce on dirait que ça m'accroche on
nettoie réalisateur le film le tc david
fincher décidé de faire un film
et y'a pas décidé de ne pas personne qui
a dit haye fait un film sur facebook lui
fait aussi une histoire qui m'intéresse
si on fait un documentaire oui c'est
encore aujourd'hui la fin de sochaux
network l'a souvent fait parce que
c'était extrêmement et comme
divinatoires mais je dis aujourd'hui on
est toutes un peu de mal à cette époque
ne s'était pas encore aussi pire que
aujourd'hui 5 demain c'est sûr mais lui
c'est ce que dans ce film là c'est
fincher où tout le monde veut faire
comme crime un film sur facebook des
jeux et ça faisait pas si longtemps que
facebook ou les moyens c'est le c'est
bizarre et comme de fait aujourd'hui tu
écoutes le film qui vieillit
parfaitement way que rien à ce fameux là
que tu fais qu'un mois on le tracé ses
débuts des réseaux sociaux si c'est
vraiment anticipateur by cette fin le me
donne des frissons quand je pense parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce on est toutes
devant nos ordis a essayé de regarder un
like d essayer de pas trop dépasser dans
notre opinion bien aussi pu trop
comédiens on les abat ou telle photo un
marché vital foods procès coûteux
relation était réseaux sociaux ça a
tellement évolué et changé j'ai un
rapport un peu amoureuse et comme j'aime
seuil
j'aime c'est y aller et qui j'aime ce
pouvoir avoir un lien direct avec les
gens qui me suivent c'est à dire que si
chara un nouveau livre tout seul j'aime
ceux qui votent génération je trouve ça
le fun aussi que vous n'êtes pas obligé
d'attendre après les médias
traditionnels pour faire une plastique
comme vous êtes en train de faire un
podcast
si vous le faire dans toute liberté
j'aime ça parce que nous allons engager
réseau qu'elle voudra parler de soi
c'est ça qui est plate
j'ai beaucoup de réflexion là dessus
parce que je trouve qu'il est vraiment
beaucoup de bons podcast avec des bonnes
en entrevue
les entrevues que tu pourrais pas
nécessairement parler de tout dans un
média traditionnel parce que comme cinq
minutes pour ton entrevue tous ceux qui
puis je me dis c'est le fun parce que
vous prenez votre place au tram à c'est
comme cela
les portes sont sont fermés le les ide
juste son blindé
vous vous trouvez votre place autrement
cela démocratise la parole oui c'est
comme un peu ça pour moi qui est une
auteure moi je suis chanceuse parce que
j'ai quand même un bel espace dans les
médias puis je me sens super
reconnaissante
mais j'ai des amis qui ont pas
nécessairement l'amour voilà la même
chance il faut pas hésiter quatre fois
tout le monde en tout genre et pilot ben
euh par leurs réseaux sociaux c'est
comme ça qu'ils peuvent annoncer leurs
sorties de livres alors qu'un certaine
époque six personnes des médias
traditionnels annonçait ton livre tu
pouvais même pas rapport à ta famille
l'annoncé toi même tu avais pas que la
forme donc ce je trouve ça
extraordinaire pour se maintenant des
témoin je le sais que on dirait qu'on
est dans une époque où tu es les réseaux
sociaux comme un jeu le voilà moi c'est
quand on emile dans un cat et demi ça
qu'on se tape tout sinon pas qu au temps
où il ya une personne m'a vu des mails
dans le khat et nitrique le toit peut
être vouloir aller le rejoindre trouvé
intéressant mais tout le monde tape
sénat le monde parle le monde luttent
comme le goût de faire chic chuchote ses
poignets du monde avec qui tu t'entends
peau oui c'est ça piquette est obligé de
cohabiter sites supports tels personnes
là on va savoir que tu les mof un
gazouillis à des affaires comme que tu
joues comme un jeu d'échecs
une drôle de nom de jeu d'échecs qui en
plus qu'assez du positif les réseaux
sociaux c'est le fun science et du
négatif c'est serov 1 et c'est moi je
suis les véhicules dans dernières années
ces gens partent souvent le mais un
commentaire négatif
contre balance sans commenter ces
chiffres
puis je sais pas pourquoi moi non plus
cette fois c'est lui qui triait ce sera
à moi que j'ai tout bien fait de faire
ces mêmes choses en attendant le podcast
t on reçoit des commentaires sur youtube
c'est juste possible aussi friands gay
qui fait genre le pire podcast j'ai
entendu ce n'est peut-être en tout c'est
vrai que ça fait comme la 2ème ou 3ème
au chalet tout le monde en parle surtout
parce que la première fois encore mais
l'allemagne à quelqu'un qui dit sur
twitter
india desjardins nos pôles et dan la
même couleur
ça m'énerve auj pis ils raison là je
peux pas c'est vrai à l'hôpital sont
plus blanches que c'est dans le pourquoi
parce que premièrement j'ai eu plein de
traitement orthodontique tiges comme
obligé d'expliquer que dis-je est
allergique ou blanches mandat ça que je
peux pas me blanchir les dames ok facto
jusqu'à chercher à expliquer j'ai juste
pleuré parce qu'il ya touché un complexe
si je veux c'est sûr que pour moi c'est
un complexe de mai mais ça a touché un
complexe parce que c'est physique qui le
sait si c'est vraiment puis des fois
aussi des gens qui vont toucher à mes
intentions c'est un magnolia de madame
ça me le dit même pas sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est en vrai mais il y avait du
monde qui disait la même chose sur les
réseaux sociaux
ça me faisait de la peine m c'était le
premier film on m'avait dit pourquoi tu
as choisi marianne c'est dur à expliquer
rationnellement quand c'est quelque
chose qui comme plus instinctive que
j'aurais pu répondre c'est instinctif
mais je sais pas je me suis perdu dans
mes explications peluches des lamas rien
en tout cas qui est la mode y est
gens qui ont pensé que j'ai dis parce
que tu es belle alors que au contraire
moi je voulais quelqu'un tic qui la
trouve belle marianne donc pour moi est
super belle comme vraiment belles girls
next door
et puis je me suis j pour ta j'avais pas
10 parce qu est belle je comprenais même
pas pourquoi on disait ça c'est comme
son déformer mes propos ou que j'avais
dit une phrase ou un bout de phrase
qu'elle avait interprété comme se piquer
non ok il faut tapoter les intentions
qui est que c'est pas du tout ya pas
vraiment de façon de gagner dans un
débat comme celui d'internet moi je le
faisais des fois les listes il répondra
devant commentaire en dessous de mes
photos pis ça finissait tout le temps
que la personne a retrouvé une affaire
que j'ai dit plus revenait sur sa à
l'homme et ont décrit un paria au
complet pour une phrase qui comme qui
ouvre un petit peu la porte à un autre
argumentaire il va ignorer tout le
paragraphe au complet pour sauter et ma
blonde a le fait mieux que moi sauf que
ça et prin
d'énergie est à s'assurer que tout le
temps mais cette année mais j'avoue
qu'au début de twitter j'avais
l'impression que c'était un est un bon
espace pour différents du pignon mac ça
m'est arrivé des fois moi aujourd'hui je
pense que je me prends penserez pour une
troll mais ça m'est déjà arrivé moins
que met-on quelqu'un partagent quelque
chose parce que je 10h vraiment pas
d'accord avec ça ou quelque chose comme
ça puis moi je pensais que ça donnait
lieu à une discussion intéressante mais
aujourd'hui plus jamais ce chiffre est
ce parce que à l'époque on dirait qu'on
suivait moins deux personnes on disait
qu'on dirait que c'était pas pareil
tandis que maintenant on est tellement à
vif parce qu'on n'est plus capable 2 2
on n'est plus capable de comment les
gens interprètent ce qu'on dit
versus interprète notre réponse versus
qu'est ce que nous on interprète de ce
que dise comment on a l'impression mais
voilà pourquoi la personne ne comprend
pas me semble que si simple qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que je vous dis qui est
vraiment qu'il va avoir un outil de
jardin mpo et telle chose dans le
journal de montréal le lendemain ça me
fait pas personne
c'est ce qui m'a fait arrêter d'écrire
des statuts personnels parce que ça me
rendait ben anxieuse finalement quand je
met un statut commence à aller après ce
se retrouver publiquement autre que sont
mes réseaux mais réseaux sociaux avec
des gens que tic que j'aime et c'est
comme ça m'était arrivé là pour une fois
on a fait ça s'était ramassé des
journaux que j'avais eu du pays tu le
dis je veux même pas répéter la fois
parce que j'en ai tellement honte mais
est métissé piste il n'y avait pas de
contexte dans la nouvelle toujours se
met à 10 km et sort de son contexte le
ca de l'afutt
c'est ce que coeur de pirate expliqué
année
j'arrête de faire des entrevues parce
que
quelque chose doit être repris à
l'expliquer le phénomène du club est
l'une des quelque chose doit être repris
pour attirer déclic loin pour attirer
déclic s'en [ __ ] si c'est véridique
si ça fait du sens avec l'entrée du
global si ça fait du sens dans son
contexte en ont rien à faire là dessus
mais qu'elle a dit moi je veux juste
arrêter de faire des entrevues pis pour
moi je comprends vraiment les artistes
qui ont pas les réseaux sociaux ouais
t'es je le comprends bien que je suis
d'accord que c'est bon pour faire ta
place puis que l'investiture rester à
l'affût par contre quand à placer fête
mais je comprends vraiment bien ce
qu'ils font jusqu'à ça m'est déjà arrivé
dans le temps que je travaillais avec
cheveux ça me pisse mans et de défendre
samso les réseaux sociaux si j'avais eu
ce pays clos une fille qui défend comme
genre et on va les violets type éclaté
alors que je défende est une blague qui
était que moi j'avais compris dans son
sens ironique mais que les gens avaient
pris littéralement je pense que guie
guie guie sésame
il disait quelque chose sa blague
c'était parce que les gens disaient que
j'étais qui était le beh oui moi puma
gagne on voit toutes venues des ce qu'on
se dit entre nous s'est marié une femme
blanche la mettre en scène
depuis 96 comme si c'était un
commentaire c'est une blague il renaît
comme support puis c'est comme si moi je
m'étais donné la mission d'expliquer la
blague
puis sami m'avait dit défends moi pas
surréagi sociaux et dit je veux je dois
me défendre moi même puis dit tu vois tu
vas te retrouver à terre teddy je sais
que tu m'aimes puis que tu que tu me
défendre de toute façon ne pas besoin de
le faire sur les réseaux sociaux parce
que ces gens-là il mérite même pas qu'on
leur accorde de l'attention qui c'est
mon job c'est quelqu'un que par ses
propos peuvent choquer ce qui est
vraiment bizarre parce que
c'est de la science comme moi c'est vrai
que tu y croit ou non le sens exercice
de mon prochain puis moi là on est
vraiment différent dans la vie c'est mon
job là il est déjà les vitamines ça sert
à rien on est dans notre alimentation
tout ça moi j'ai plein d'autres
vitamines des jeux des gp lui là
maintenant j'arrive avec des nouvelles
vitamines pied mais voyons cela
oui mais c'est franc brossé 30 pis le
cpie jeux des îles veux pas me chicaner
ou n'importe quoi te jeter lui il me le
dit que il me dit que les vitamines
j'ai pas besoin de dépenser mon argent
là dessus j'ai l'information à pression
et oblige pas les gens c'est que lui il
donne les faits scientifiques de 2 x bow
coiffeur mais non c'est certain quand
même année avait fait tout un bébé sur
les cures détox parce que moi je bois
beaucoup de jus j'aime beaucoup les jus
frais mais gelé je prends pas en cure
j'aime les juges m soit un jus de
carotte des citrons été bon je te montre
paix qui lui battait y avait fait toute
une bd là-dessus pitié pilote moi
j'avais partagé la bd alsace où cela dit
moi j'ai comme une fan des jupes mais je
lui mets empêche pas de bord dit jules
c'est acquis en bois de trousse un bon
mec c'est intéressant le fait maintenant
en quoi ce fait l'autre te heurtes c'est
justement ça me heurte pas comme en 2010
parce que moi le oui j'ai déjà fait la
recherche quand je voyais maintenant les
cure de jus j'ai déjà fait la recherche
en moins cure de jus mais sa cure quoi
je trouvais rien été je trouvais
maintenant les sites des packs sait sauf
que moi ça m'intéressait de voir baisse
c'est vraiment un oui ça peut même cure
et son curieux puis on a parlé justement
avec lui sur ce podcast l'hôpital
soyez des gens qui ont
je m arrête des gens qui sentent que
quelque chose à régler cherche des
solutions plus à voir je sais la cure
détox d'amadeus puis c'est subtil 4 le
cpo tu le sais pas typique on n'est pas
avec un esprit critique est parfait être
parfaitement aiguisé concert connaître
sans imputer vous devez fait j'aime
beaucoup
olivier tendre enfance puis je suis ce
qui fait pas ça l'à beaucoup aidé a
aiguisé mon esprit que 6e puis d'autres
choses mais je prends moi dans l'erreur
d'emprunt d'affaires encore peut-être
que même que lui amener votre rencontre
et c'est tout cas telle affaire que je
pensais que l'huile puis moi ont des
fois on a des débats sur certains sujets
là là il décide de faire une grosse
recherche d'un gardien qui me dit bon
les fesses et sociaux maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on en
pense
james o parce que lui il va aller au
fond des choses tout ça mais c'est sûr
que sur les réseaux sociaux ce soit hier
soit vraiment qui moi car tu es le plus
le québec tire quand je les rencontre et
s est sûr que pour moi c'était
confrontant parce que si moi je fais et
aurélie laflamme et si je veux dire à
part le tollé dans gens nous aider à
faire de même a pas eu et il y en a même
qui disent ah j'aime pas ça vous gêne
pas son reer à l'allemagne 1 0
si c'est des affaires locaux et je peux
pas m'en défendre peter moment donné tu
peux pas m année là avant avant un
réseau commuté pozzoli avant les réseaux
sociaux le quai je faisais des
chroniques au canal vox puis monsieur
qui avait appelé pour dire qu'ils aiment
et pour mourir dans sa lola et lui je ne
sais pas comment changer c'est vrai mais
bref c'est sûr que moi quand je les ai
rencontrés au début
vraiment je me demandais comment il
faisait
joie ce qui m'impressionne enlèvement
parce qu'il ya une tolérance à ceux à
confronter le monde qui ça dérange pas
que c'est ce que je pense que ça lui ce
même si lisbonne est censé je pense que
personne n'aime se faire insulter
ouais mais mettons je vous donne un
exemple rapidement kaki venu ici le
temps tes pieds comme je répète que je
laime coopi jeu tangre enfin métier il
rapporté après 30 secondes on parle de
podcast à écouter le podcast puis le
moose dit tout bonnement band autonome
bai john logan puis il peut espérer
appartient pas de casse plis dit amadou
gon celle des tests avaient 30 secondes
je le connais avec les pythies lui dit
suce pas naturellement pour bien me
heurte et non juste pour qu'on a ici
c'est pas méchant mais c'est beaucoup
moins que ce serait retenue de quelque
chose comme cela quelqu'un qui vienne
rencontrer puis moi je trouve ça drôle
et mêmes mais dans ce cas en même temps
on a le droit de se plaindre de ces
choses d'avoir une discussion civilisée
oui pis si je reviens on est aux réseaux
sociaux
j'aime autant que dans le discours plan
climat on est de plus en plus de misère
avec les opinions divergent loin des
quêtes une nuance toutefois cette école
et soins
pis ces bénévoles je trouve ouais puis
moi ce que je trouvais du styliste est
d'être la blonde de lui puis j'avais pas
si j'avais pas été souvent exposé à
autant de ce qui est
qui écoute après son passage à tout le
monde en parle je recevais manceau
insultes c'est l'eau au lait la dernière
fois que je vais aller on en parle peu
que je l'avais dit c'est comme si je
suis devenu un moment donné madame
pharmacie au lieu de papier déjà non
seulement des insultes mais déjà des
fois qu'ils me demandent des conseils à
moi ça c'est certain
monsieur michaud pharmacie où tu es
petit demandé à olivier telle affaire
bemba moi moi il ya une parce que j'ai
trouvé ça dur par moment donné il m'a
dit un peu la même affaire que ça mais
m'a dit ça tu appartiens port est obligé
de me défendre
t'es pas obligé parce que des fois je
t'ai portée on dirait à vouloir le
défendre
qui disait ça tu appartiens pas ça
m'appartient c'est mon choix puis ces
oublis surf avec des fois il ya des
affaires que je veux pas lire défaut
l'ifop
un peu pour rire parce que je trouve ce
je trouve ce trop ridicule
la dernière fois que je les répare que
je les défends anduze lui ça l'affectait
pas c'est moi que ça a affecté mais
c'est quand que sorti son livre quand il
y avait du quai qui sortait son livre le
petit garçon que pose la question il y
avait plein de commentaires puis pains
le plein de commentaires
pourquoi pas la fille puis sami écoute
ça méritait pas la femme noire et
camille d'accord c'est quoi cette s'en
prennent ce que les femmes en science
n'ont pas leur place non change sans un
livre pour enfants petits mois jetant
goff actu talent et avec un petit peu
parce que c'est ce que je connais un peu
basé sur moi c'est plus de ce texte que
ce au nom ce post it mine de rien et
c'est demain tu es donc moi c'est un
syrien avec moi ça ma vie
à fait que j'avais fait un statut je
pense que j'ai un moment donné mon j'ai
arrêté de faire des statuts parce que
j'étais le h20 statut le pense dans
logic ripaud parce que j'essaye de chez
quiche bras pieds mais le jeu mettait
forcer le plus je peser chaque mot le
parce que tu es je savais que ça pouvait
être repris ou pas été repris ou si je
savais que les gentils ils pouvaient me
depuis ce statut là j'en ai pour fait
d'autres parce que ça demande l'énergie
donne son opinion sur quelque chose pour
pige à la discussion
pis moi on dirait que tu sais si tu le
lis paul dérange pas si tu le vois pas
c'est l'autre jour j'ai coûté un sou
écoute le programme accorde avec boucar
diouf team godillots qui est passée
réseaux sociaux pour notamment de le
hisser dans un timing push de deux je
maintiens que les jours de tempête dans
moins de monde qu'ils l'aiment pas il
sait poppy moins pendant la marche dans
ses ruelles ses enfants pays bas ne
redoute rien et moi j'ai envie qu'ils me
serais pas capable
j'avoue que je sais pas vous mais moi
j'avoue que
j'ai trop le bras dans l'engrenage j'ai
trop des beaux souvenirs sur facebook
j'ai mes souvenirs sur ce que c'est à la
mode crash mais j'ai fait j'ai des
souvenirs sur facebook le que ça me
ferait de la peine de perdre des
souvenirs sont instagram aussi ou ou un
lien avec des lecteurs ou même avec des
amis que je voit pas si souvent que
normalement viger vert et pop que le ch
contenter de voir leurs enfants grandir
ou des choses comme ça donc je serais
pas capable de revenir en arrière même
si j'ai j'ai peur
ces jeux plus vieille que vous puissiez
sûr que manger j'ai connu un avant et un
après plongez que j'écoutais lavez vous
les écoutez américaine même sur netflix
non ma blonde à l'excès j'étais vraiment
comme ok je viens je me sentais bien
j'étais ok je comprends peut-être plus
la vie loin mais le mot je trouve que ça
ça change de plus en plus vite savoir si
on ne reçut fou qui si tu connais ce
temps viendra pas excellent non 22e puis
si j'avais une certes le c5 à 5,6 a dit
shah des jeux un petit cigare depuis le
pis le tpiy mais tu mets ton moi je mets
je voudrais faire un point des deux
jardins moi même puis écrire une quelque
chose qui se passe au secondaire je sais
pas si je serai pas capable d'écrire
quelque chose que les jeunes et je sais
pas ça oui parce que jusqu'à n'est plus
la réalité audrey c'est pas important ce
puis moi je les ai souvent au début de d
aurélie les jeunes de n'importe quelle
époque de n'importe quel pays
c'est tout le temps les mêmes émotions
c'est jusqu'à technologique change
thé dansant ce que tu lis un âne la
maison pillant verbe tulle et aurélie
c'est les mêmes émotions le cnom qui
sont racontées puis moi c'est quelque
chose que j'ai toujours c'est maintenant
le faire un travail que tu te rappelles
de toit ou selon dans le bain des
émotions les émotions sont vécues par
d'autres monde aujourd'hui mais avec une
différentes technologies coin tout juste
aurait juste besoin de faire quelques
petites recherches pour juste savoir
tout comme
bon si tout le monde est maintenant un
téléphone cellulaire si la blague juste
des petites informations factuelles
comme ceux pour les rajouter mais
l'adolescence que toto vécu c'est la
même adolescence quand un garçon de 15
ans en ce moment qui moi comme âgées
j'ai découvert ce c'est que moi quand
j'écris aurélie le premier j'ai appelé
ces extraterrestres ou presque parce que
ça décrivait le sentiment que moi
j'avais vécu à mon âge et mon
adolescence des j'écris aurélie à 30 ans
puis j'écris pour les gens rentrent
douzy césar mais tant mieux si c'est
fermé pression quand même que sa hotte a
résonné ouais mais je suis allé vraiment
connecté à mon cas d'événement est mort
de ton expérience des descentes j'avais
encore ses émotions au look qui
accrochait un peu pied écoute le livre
et au québec
bon il est en france et en allemagne y
est en ait si tu peux de savoir plus
différent qui voyons j'arrête pas de
cacher mais c'est donc au dessus
quelque chose de plus différent qu'un
jeune letton en france un jeune à et
haïti l'on s'entend c'est pas du tout la
même vie et ils me disent les mêmes
affaires les mêmes commentaires en
utilisant les mêmes mots en utilisant
les mêmes genres d'expression donc les
sentiments c'est universel qui allons
êtres humains aujourd'hui pour un être
humain dans le temps c'est juste l'aide
la technologique change vite
l'impression que réaliste 9
intemporelles et universelles et
intemporelles je sais pas parce que j'ai
fait une erreur une petite gaffe qui est
de mettre beaucoup de références
culturelles parce que moi je savais pas
c'est une gaffe pour la temporalité pour
le point la perpétuité de l'oeuvre
ouais c'est ça tu sais comme moi je me
je mange pensais pas que ça allait avoir
une pérennité dans la mesure où j'ai
appris ce cash présenter le film oz 100
unités
il me faisait
est-ce qu'elle oeuvre une terrine people
mais mais je pensais que tu imaginais de
l'univers des magazines non je pensais
que le livre durer un ou deux seraient
punis a pris donc
et je sais pas si ça va être un temps
pour elle comme tu as dit tantôt c'est
le temps nous dira je suis quand même
content parce que aujourd'hui encore des
nouvelles lectrices
s'il ya une nouvelle génération qui
découvrait le fait qu'il y en a tout le
temps des nouveaux mais est ce que un
c'est je sais pas combien de temps ça va
durer
c'est vraiment ça tombe directement dans
le sujet un sujet qui est intéressant
pour nous parce qu'on a en main une
qualification de nos autres stores
perpétuelle puis on peut poser des
questions aux invités davance puis ici
on à alexandre aventure à giroud qui
pose une question qui rejoint vraiment
ce qu'on dit le jeu vers la question des
options on en parle donc bonjour les
gars et bonjour india voici ma question
c'est l'histoire du premier tomb
d'aurélie laflamme aurait lieu en 2019
reçu fait d'elle une influence euse s
qui leur est usée youtube les réseaux
sociaux pour se confier
merci est-ce que tu aurait changé la
façon
d'aborder sa communication
si ça avait été si tu avais réécrire ce
aujourd'hui tu parles de les sentiments
sont les mêmes mais la technologie
change parce que maintenant on voit de
plus en plus des personnes sur les
réseaux sociaux je suis contre ceux
confiés tbilissi ce que le monde cherche
maintenant le monde ils veulent plus
voir juste tout ce qui est beauté des
photos de voyage plutôt que les kits
veulent voir du monde n'ont pas grand
chose
j'aurais pas changé la technologie parce
que pour moi le mot terrible parce que
pour moi c'est une question d'intimité
il ya des affaires aurélie qui fait
honte qu'il a faire réfléchir et ce qui
pour moi j'ai utilisé la forme journal
mais j'ai joué avec cette formule parce
qu'il ya des fois des choses en temps
réel des fois il ya des choses dans le
passé des fois donc non j'aurais pas
changé de la technologie parce que c'est
comme si pour moi ça pourrait être
n'importe quelle technologie peut
l'imaginer en train de dire tout ça sur
youtube
à la limite peu mais pour moi la
question que ça se passe dans sa tête
puis que la question d'un oui ça reste
avec les mêmes pour moi c'est super
important dans l'histoire qui est parce
que comme en jeu près de 7 des fois il
ya des affaires le que mince qu'on file
sur youtube ne va pas dire parce que des
affaires qui étaient trop honte aux
besoins de le deal est avec toi même
puis aurélie moi il ya beaucoup de tuer
beaucoup d'affaires qui compte qu'ils
avaient dit les ça avec elle même mois
comprend papier c'est comme ces aveux
médecins en place avant d'être capable
de d'avancé par rapport à ceux donc
j'aurai pas changé j'aurais pas changer
la forme puis je pense pas qu alors et
influenceurs en fait dans le tome 9 à
l'essai et ça marche pas elle appelle sa
famille genre pouvez-vous l'argument
vidéo
parce que son buzz parce que et à
travers un travail dans un magazine
jeunesse place on bosse dix mois mais le
skippeur maintenant c'est d'être
youtuber influenceurs tous sont donc pas
qu on allait à ces seuils de faire une
recette ou tout ça marche pas piller et
ça c'est intéressant puis ça reste dans
la dans la lignée de dire que c'est une
fille ordinaire wiki qui était commun
comme un cadeau divin youtube buzz tpour
pour une le lisanne nadeau pour une
baisse qu'il faut du succès comme cana
qui essaie ça lève petit et plus de
monde qui voit qu'ils vont être rejoints
la réalité c'est que t'es pas toujours
la personne qui sort du lot puis aurélie
pour moi c'est ce a fait son propre
chemin c'est un chemin qui est qui qui
différencie les hommes à l'époque son
chemin il ya été différente et à le
porter à l'heure un chemin atypique
maintenant il y en a d'autres mais mais
c'est ce donc pour moi c'était plus ça
rejoignait plus justement mon thème de
cette une fille ordinaire
kouici elle essaye de faire un vidéo
youtube 10 euros personne qui veut
l'écouter c'est bon c'est ta famille
puis c'est pas mal sa famille qu'elle a
appelée pas fait ma façon de devenir
virale n'est pas très moderne
bon mais une bonne élection j'ai mieux
de j'aime cela la conscience ou là la
tension a gardé quelque chose de
personnel personnel - tpe c'est plus en
plus difficile chez marie aude gardé de
garder ce kit est proche
témoin je le vis bien le cas mais mon
quotidien comme si j'ai six chutes plus
absents aussi maintenant je me montrent
pas tout le temps que ma blonde j'en
suis toujours des commentaires ou encore
ans en vendant une voie encore ensemble
et h à toutes les fois où elle est c'est
pire comme le mahb l'on est à los
angeles pisser constant le ca tous les
jours ses services milo le tc rouen caen
sans même devoir en sentez vous
il en a mais tant que je plonge plus
avec la cité trouvaient engagés de
séparer ma bon centre tendu de vivre
seul de mon bord s'attendent pas à voir
tout le monde qui me pose la question
leezam justement ils sont séparés
dernièrement avec son coin pis ça a duré
deux mois sans que la longue mais
imaginez le nombre de figures mans ça
devait être pesant oui surtout que j'ai
vu après votre podcast lisant cet objet
qui se dit ici et je me disais mon dieu
si c'est ça pour moi de vieille de 42
ans belge peu vieille le métier vous
comprenez plus vieille que vous ce pour
moi ça dépasse ma compréhension
c'est quelque chose que c'est nouveau
pour moi puis que si que c'est quelque
chose que
que j'ai de la misère à comprendre les
attentes des déjantés la barre haut pour
youtube heures aux influenceurs mais en
même temps si tu vit par l'épée tumeurs
par les ce1 petit c'est un choix qui
fait d'être dans l'oeil du public puisse
a cessé ses avantages et ses
inconvénients partie des inconvénients
c'est surtout si surtout si le
ton style de vie ton mode de vie est
intrinsèquement liée à succès un cat est
un artiste mettant comme toile et les
réseaux sociaux t'es pas dépendante des
réseaux sociaux au sens où pas sûr
toutefois tout ton succès près réseaux
sociaux tcc ton histoire du succès à
aller à l'existant dehors des réseaux
sociaux mais aujourd'hui l'histoire du
succès des jeunes c'est à travers
l'histoire de succès à ceux qui
réussissent et ceux qui ont et millions
d'abonnés sa sacoche ça comme changé
c'est que le succès vrai que quelques
exemples cpo se tait mais ton chemin là
où le rapport là en ce moment et
planétaire ces réseaux sociaux ça existe
pauvres et matija pas vraiment de succès
qui balance est resté chanteur au site
il ya manière de contourner ça mais ça
fait quand même partie de l'équation
même si quand on note un truc principal
seuil bas le noir la route serait
peut-être pas explosé tant que cio
doublé 56 paris au double des clés pour
l'udps et amuse le plus c'est sur
youtube que ce récit c'est ce qui rend
ce planétaire on est ce la beauté versus
les inconvénients pis on a on dirait
qu'on n'a pas d'exemple on n'a pas
encore de règles par rapport à internet
pour ne pas encore trouvé les grecs de
brink des bienséances au pôle social
intéressant d'apprendre aux enfants la
politesse mais sur internet ça se
transforme en demeure comme ça on fait
l'analogie un peu avec la naissance du
monde c'est parce que si c'est la
naissance d'un monde se voit comme la
naissance du monde et
bon le tu regarde toutes les époques y
perdrait qu'on peut reproduire toutes
les époques puis un moment donné il
votre savoir des lois un policier kid
est sans aucun doute celle interne est
encore une grosse jungle et puis ça ne
sera pas une grosse joie est définie
mais je l'apprécié pas c'est qu'à un
moment donné il ya de la violence et une
voix tout et tout de suite eu l'épisode
des simpson ou lisa a créé un monde ok
puis j'ai voulu ce padd qui évoluent à
la alors perdu le contrôle en direct à
internet des fois on m'a fait passer ces
textes c'est quelque chose qui est
embêtant avec un mécanisme en branle qui
est inarrêtable rendu le web évolue à
une vitesse folle depuis qu'ils ont le
contrôle on va le perdre le ramener
c'est ce qui c'est qui qui va faire les
lois puis c'est qui qui voulait
appliquer puis tout ce qui est
disponible comme année le lycée les gens
vont pas faire et mon dieu tu allé trop
loin
ce soir j'ai regardé le documentaire
trou les les trolls l'oeil avide madame
celle ci a l'air bon alain omont madame
à laver à la vie elle avait france
menacée de mort quelqu'un pleut pénélope
mcquade lui demande bien pourquoi vous
avez fait ce que je comprends et je n'ai
juste avoir un ordinateur je comprenais
pas comment ça marche
même si je comprends pot commun
s'affrontent le dan meyer scénario
c'était qu'au québec c'est moi le
meilleur scénario était elle à l'avant
les exemples des gens qui comprend pas
c'est plus jamais quelqu'un qui est
écrit et tam a quitté cristowall du
souper
[Musique]
galeriste juste des personnes qui sait
pas comment facebook fonctionner ou
pillées il y avait monsieur son west est
remplit de gens
google 2 points il y avait dix demandes
à google fait que le lièvre la demande à
google écrit google s'est attiré la
foule des personnes comme si alors il
est temps changent les temps changent
mais penses tu que tu pourrais
parfaite votre continuer à écrire des
mets ton de la littérature
disons jeunesse mais ça fait mal c'est
comme moi j'ai écrit ces avant d'écrire
aurélie j'ai écrit un roman qui était
comme une comédie romantique a précisé
qu'il est aurélie après ça j'ai fait des
bd apprécié j'ai fait un autrement une
comédie romantique pour adultes après ce
que j'ai écrit une autre bd
après ça j'ai écrit des contes et il lui
a dit que de terminer sa vidéo comme
survenue avec avec aurélie c'est moi le
jem se suivent mans car j'ai pas capable
de faire quelque chose que ça vient paul
d'une pulsion de mon coeur je sais pas
vraiment quelque chose que j'ai envie de
faire dans ce moment le sait le jce
voyons industries ce qui m'avait
approché pour écrire des petits livres
pour enfants dans une collection calé
dans sa maison d'édition puis au début
j'avais dit non je sentais pas bien à un
moment donné j'ai fait oh mon dieu j'ai
l'idée pour ta collection le jeu les
fêtes mais j'aurais pas été capable de
le faire quand j quand j'ai dit non plus
j'ai eu une idée j'ai tripé plus j'écris
ce projet fou le trip et à faire ce pas
que c'est pour moi ça peut être pour
pilotes voici une collection pour
enfants donc ça peut être pour enfants
ça peut être pourra dire si moi je me
mets pas de l'immigration je me dis pas
acheter notre jeunesse est une autre
piste à mal les gens ça me dérange pas
autiste pas mon problème c'est que tu
vois la sphère que j'ai moins de 10km
ning parce qu'ils y trouvent un petit
défaut c'est que j'aime pas ce que ses
autres livres l'écrivain sous un autre
nom paraît chez j'ai de la misère à
comprendre je comprends son point au
début qu'à voulait prendre un nom
d'homme comme pour prouver un point qui
est ce que si j'étais un homme puis je
fais des romans policiers ça va être
plus ça va être plus lus ou acheter tout
mais maintenant que tout prouve et on
pointe c'est qu'est ce qui fait que tu
continues tu réveilles à quelque chose
comme ça c'est pas la première
ses livres mais moi je ferais pas ce mot
si j'amène les gens
le je m'en fous c'est peut-être aussi
qui était tellement qu'à un nom aussi un
homme qui est que le sien les attentes
sont tellement hôtelier demandez
peut-être que des fois ça fait du bien
de dire que je recommence de zéro voire
jusqu'à pas de reconstruire quelque
chose avec toi je l'aï rit jamais ce que
je me distingue mal c'est ce qu'elle a
vraiment changé
est ce que va changer de nom parce qu'il
aurait envoyé des manuscrits à des
maisons d'édition le nom c'est le pam a
changé de nom et avec son manuscrit à 10
busson valiquer quelque part que c'est
moi puis c'est sur son twitter a dit je
pense que des fois quelque chose si je
pense pas qu'ils reparti à zéro
complètement parce qu'il y avait il y
avait l'histoire de romain gary
ouais on ne guérit pas mais là j'en
rêvais cornet coin lui il pouvait pas
gagner tu peux pas gagner deux fois le
concours hippique la gorgue et une fois
alors j avais dit je vais prendre le nom
d'emile ajar pour qu'ils tel nom ton
cousin je pense pour essayer de regagner
un deuxième fois ça c'est cool parce que
s'il ya quelque chose qui fait que parce
que si les gens savaient pas ça veut
dire qu'il ya un réel talent oui c'est
sûr que les gens ne savaient pas parce
que parce que sinon je pense texte st
chamas était son cousin où son beau
frère parce qu'ils sont beaux frappe son
beau frère c'est lui qui faisait les
entrevues ces malades quand même ce que
ça fait partie de la légende
mais pour rené à ce que tu sais pas ce
que ça va sonner une cloche dans trop de
mal et on publie khl
nous autres on le vit un peu avec le
podcast métier on souhaite du monde du
web après sont soit des gens comme toi
on soit en soi des chefs ont su attirer
du monde des entrepreneurs monde de
gauche comme de droite ont su du monde
de partout pirates
c'est sur la forme ce concept but on
sait dire s'ils ont mal le public
so so what my on s'en fout je pense
qu'on a réussi en guillemets en enfer
notre marque de commerce comme on
ratisse large
métis et c'est sûrement meilleur mettons
pour l'algorithme you tube de rick et je
vois niche et l affaire pour foncer là
dedans mais moi je trouve ça l'fun
qu'évidemment le monde qui nous suivent
sont portés à a écouté du monde qui
aurait jamais découvert bâti non le tuer
moi c'est ce qui m'arrive quand je quand
j'écoute votre podcast mais je trouve ça
l'fun parce que vous ratisser large
puisque seules femmes parce que vous
avez vous n'êtes pas parti avec un
préjugé envers moi tig parce que j'écris
et des livres jeunesse depuis que c'est
pas un sarment peut-être même dans vos
intérêts haute-somme et vous avez la
curieuse parce que le goût est un
écrivain jeunesse donc il écrit des
livres jeunesse parce que j'avais déjà
lu ce mois j'ai écrit pour les éditions
post 1 je n'ai pas senti fondé des
livres pour les jeunes du primaire
secondaire salle de lecture
moi j'écrivais des camps pour ça mais je
veux poser mais je vais aller regarder
ça va aller regarder les moi c'était
plus pour les jeunes du primaire du fait
que c'est un petit peu plus jeunes
pièces qu'on trouve en librairie
ouais librairie avec exemple mais c'est
surtout les écoles les commissions
scolaires commencent aux éditions
directement c'est ce qu'un casse et des
livres
je vous pédagogique comme ce que je vais
écrire spéciaux c'est le cas je disais
les livres pour enfants avec ce serait
peut-être même pas à libérer donc des
fois c'est pour ça qu'on connaît moins
mais ces otages alors définitivement
petit mois ci est pas vendu mon nom tu
le fais bien mon nom est là mais quand
faut que tu cherches trop bref y'a pas
de préjugés parti je trouve ça l'fun qui
est même cité d'emblée c'est comme si on
voit pas d'un serment lien puis pourtant
notre conversation est super intéressant
on est sûr qu'ils peuvent fixer le fan
de votre part d'être ouvert plein de
choses plein de sujets c'est ce qu'on
ressent aussi quand vous écoutez vos
questions sont son pote et où
de votre perception vous avez une
curiosité vous avez envie c'est moi j'ai
toujours priorisé dans ma vie de
ratisser large
avoir un intérêt c'est moche de la
musique dans la vie même en musique si
j'aurais pu décider de dire moi je fais
que pratique et huit heures par jour la
guitare puis je donner le meilleur
guitariste j'ai paumé la guitariste au
québec mais ton mais je fais la
réalisation d'albums je fais des tiges
ou un peu de tout être humain par
exemple conférence
ok parce que moi le comment c'est
comment j'ai commencé à travailler il
sait que au magazine cool au monde me
pose des questions maudit et navigue du
billet sur internet questions bizarres
pour vous autres parce que moi qu'avec
nos affaires avec des disquettes raconte
là parce que trop bon petit soldat
anglais puis j'avais dit oui aux deux
puis je m'étais dit si m'engage je veux
apprendre l'anglais
je vais apprendre à surfer même défaut
d'un autre côté j'avais un charme qui
était guitariste gris qui se
pratiquaient ces pratiques et jeter
l'eau mais vous donner ton nom telle
classe venues tendances pratiques et se
pratiquait pas ce qui serait encore mais
quitte à se faire dire non
quitte à devoir travailler plus fort
quitte à tizi fausse met en danger puis
les deuils les défis c'est ce qui fait
avancer
mais si tu fais dire non car je me suis
fait dire non comme jk rowling comme
c'est cambrai monde se sont fait jour
non un non c'est pas la fin des fois le
juge pour des cons couple il ya des
jeunes qui me disent mais j'ai pas été
choisi comme dirait
m'améliorer j'ai tellement continue ce
que tu fais c'est subjectif c'est
surtout pour un métier artistique ou
même pour influenceurs c'est subjectif
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire que
quelqu'un vous dit si quelqu'un
quelqu'un vous voici quelqu'un d'autre
quelqu'un vous aimez un texte quelqu'un
me repose quelqu'un va aimer de la
musique quelqu'un est subjectif donc
continuer à faire ce que tu aimes
puisque tu fais puis à un moment donné
il ya quelqu'un qui va peut-être
accrocher sinon non berne - le ya plein
de choses que j'ai essayé dans ma vie
qui n'ont pas marché
je pense que l'important c'est pas que
tous les rêves soit possible comme c'est
super à la mode de dire mais c'est que
d'être capable de 15 rêve fonctionne pas
appris que tout fait pour persévérer là
non c'est d'essayer de renouveler pour
iphone en essayant un autre on eu
exactement des conversations de mopi
parce que le pot longtemps puis pis si
oui il faut persévérer il faut essayer
il faut suivre ses rêves métier et où la
limite de 6 ou qui devient comme les
mains dans l'illusion la septième année
il faut trouver la balance le réaliste
puis à manger il faut que tu dises
dompter que cette chose le cepos tôt
pour moi pour voir autre chose pythie et
chacun a quelque chose à offrir je gagne
quelque chose dans quelques i qui bonté
juin super j'en suis convaincu je vais
rebondir sur ça parce que dans ces
discussions là qui ont donné exactement
l'exemple de jk rowling
parce qu'on s'en sort souvent pitois
étonné que ton exemple est semblable
curieux de savoir qu'est ce que tu
penses de ce on donne on donne souvent
l'exemple de jk rowling qui se veut dire
non mais que ça finit par dire oui on se
fait dire les babys taux se sont fait
refuser par des maisons de disques puis
ça finit par dire oui
mais on parle vraiment moins souvent 99%
monde qui écrivent des manuscrits qui
sont jugés jamais publié zing et envoie
ce à toutes les maisons d'édition du
québec qui mollet j'en ai les gens j'en
connais personnellement du monde qui
pense que ça va fonctionner qui sont
rendus à leur troisième manuscrit d'une
saga de fantasy épique
les deux premiers ont pas été publiés ne
le portent pas continuer à envoyer les
troisièmes à toutes les maisons
d'édition piqueuse autres reçoivent sur
pis ils lisent peut-être qu'ils lisent
le début qui se disent ça l'fait juste
pas plus que douter ou peut-être qu'ils
offrent à une vedette de farine autobus
possiblement si ça se peut que ça sopon
le talent de la personne mais mais là la
situation justement le créneau dans quel
s embarque août cpie mai
enfin on peut
je réfléchis à word mais comment
commence là limités ou la limiter ou en
croire à des histoires des histoires
comme la tienne comme celle de jk
rowling qui existe réellement
phi phi croire un peu de façon lunatique
ton histoire à toi à tcc comment tu
t'accroches assez parce qu'on s'accroche
à l'histoire de succès mais tina mais un
succès le choix des racontez moi je
voulais être porteur à flash passer des
auditions à chaque année à manier je me
suis rendu demi finalistes finalement
j'ai pas été choisi je voulais être
chroniqueur à bla bla bla quitter une
émission où valtat finalement j'ai pas
été choisi et j'ai envoyé mes mais mon
démo dans des émissions comme simple je
n'ai jamais choisis qui un moment donné
je me suis juste dit est ce que c'est
vraiment ce que je veux faire ma vie
puis qu'est ce que j'aime vraiment c'est
quoi - qu'est-ce que je faisais
naturellement quand j'étais petit
est-ce que c'est pis c'est là que j'ai
essayé j'ai juste essayé autre chose qui
finalement apte et j'écrivais mon
histoire j'avais hâte de me lever le
matin fait que j'ai changé mon rêve
parce que oui je me suis je me serais
amené à me questionner sur bon puis on
dirait que l'on me faire dire non est
émis premiers noms mais si leur j'avais
eu juste des noms sur mon romain
peut-être je réside en écrire un autre
puis d'envoyer un autre mais un moment
donné j'aurais trouvé quelque chose doit
quitter le succès le sait éphémère faite
moi là ok ça fonctionne et aurélie
piloter et ça va ça va bien ce que
j'écris mais ça se peut que moment donné
le plus personne qui veut lire de mes
livres puis que je trouve plus de
contrats en écriture mais je suis
capable de me dire que je veux je veux
trouver autre chose
moi qui tu ça me fait pas plaisir parce
que je fais ma passion ce moment ça
c'est sûr que ça m'angoisse de passation
mais je reste pourtant les pieds sur
terre en me disant ça peut arriver ça
peut arriver que je doive dans ma vie me
trouver un nouveau rêve même si ça
arrive ce que te crées ça va rester
longtemps resté le fait c'est comme
c'est comme les bente bob dylan va
encore de la musique mais personne
vraiment qu'ils les cotillons
aujourd'hui mais c'est un des plus
grands poètes qui est le plus grand
artiste qui existe et a laissé sa marque
fait que tu es si c'est pas grave a mené
de porter le flambeau je pense lorsque
entité ouvert les vannes de manu dans ta
vie pit c'est faux n'est pas étonnante
avait envers soi même puis j'espère que
j'espère que je vais que je vais être
capable de light de renouveler mon rêve
à ce moment là mais est ce que tu penses
que la suggestion que j'avais eu un
mitraillage d'une direction mais est ce
que tu penses que la littérature c'est
un des derniers un des derniers grands
ports qui est pas de démocratiser encore
que ça veut dire
admettons l'amusé cloutier pour
reprendre l'exemple de bob dylan était
la musique maintenant six mois je vais
écouter un auteur compositeur interprète
jose spotify j'en ai un million qui
offrent leurs compositions 1 millions de
créateurs de musique qui me moque du
contenu si je veux lire un livre
il ya des instances de légitimisation
comme des maisons d'édition qui sont qui
eux au travail tu ris parce que du monde
auto publié il ya un homme et leurs
livres sont pas distribués sont pas lu
le tir si moi je veux lire un livre pour
que le livre soit rendue aux archambault
renaud bray ou dans n'importe quelle
librairie indépendante
il ya du monde qui l'ont emmené là le
monde qu'il en est là et il fonctionne
comme n'importe quelle compagnie par
gage de succès puis quand tu publies
india desjardins le nom va vendre des
livres aux sociétés qui ton nom ma
question c'est en littérature le nom il
reste j'ai l'impression plus que dans
d'autres ports qui maintenant sont
rendus accessibles vraiment tout le
monde je pense pas tout les auteurs
seraient d'accord avec toi tu es
maintenant certains auteurs que leur
troisième livre mettant au moins
fonctionné et s'assure c'est sûr que si
ton livre son lait mais moins bon depuis
que la critique dit que c'est moins bon
il va être moins lutter des fois aussi
par exemple on encourage la relève puis
des fois quand il un peu mais de 9
d'euros depuis que ça des trucs c'était
comme paul espèce de poche de jean
nouvel sur ce parce qu'un musée qui a
beaucoup ce tce en charge beaucoup la
nouveauté enfin tandis que littérature
pas tant que - peut-être parce que tu
vois maintenant je pense à patrick
senécal tout le monde et tout un
contente que les reins patrick senécal
parce qu'on sait que ça va être ce que
ça va divertir
6 - témoin c'est un super bon livre de
vacances pour moitié entre les deux le
fait que mettons ce soit pas de nouveau
que ce soit pas alors qu'en musique on
va chercher beaucoup plus ce nouveau
témoin des fois ce que je trouve injuste
par rapport à la musique pc si la
musique c'est je trouve que les
musiciens sont peu chanceux parce que
justement leur musique a été fait et
comme tellement accessible de façon
gratuite comme moi l'autre jour moi
j'achète tout à mes albums ce jeu très
vieux jeu par abbas mais pas
physiquement la mèche des achats sur
itunes puis leur manie c'était possible
je n'étais plus capable d'écouter
m'amuser ce plu finalement il fallait
que je m'abonne puis le ménage peut plus
acheter juge s'abonner pour m'amuser je
comprends même pas comment c'est arrivé
qui se sait vraiment le genre dans son
dos par mois une musique qui j'ai un
infini de musique alors que moi avant je
faisais mes choix mais sélection moi
même mais le c'était comme plus possible
parce que j'arrêtais pas de recevoir des
notifications sur
chez nous je n'étais pas sûr wife et je
pouvais pas écouté ma propre musique
les coutures peut-être ben les affaires
que je comprends pas la dame et le temps
de télécharger plus tard ling le pire
c'est que le ch comme mais qu'est-ce que
je fasse je comprends pop hits dit c'est
donc mais le livre on devrait pour
l'instant on passe sous le radar par
rapport à ce que je trouve ça quand même
assez une chance et parce que c'est sûr
et certain qu'un moment donné les les
musiciens quand leur musique mais en
même temps ça c'est celle à être humain
qui résume bien aussi il ya plein de
musiciens qui disent ben finalement ça
m'a aidé et et comme tu parlais de là
c'est finalement le fait que sa musique
soit démocratisé que ça faisait
accessible partout dans le monde puis
finalement bain et a vendu des albums
partout dans le monde mais il y en a
d'autres à qui ses nuits parce que
mettons si leur musique est plus c'est
comme diriger vers le québec bien le
fait que ça soit accessible au monde
c'est moins pertinent tout ça et enlève
des revenus donc si je trouve que le
livre moi des fois je me questionne sauf
qu'à ce que savent ce que l'avenir du
lycée quoi l'avenir je vois je vois pas
pourquoi cette révolution on le touche
finira par toucher le livre aussi les
gens lisent des livres sur leur ipad si
ils pourraient avoir les fesses de
banques bête il ya déjà des banques
délivrent métier on est un auteur
pourrait dire où je mets mon livre
internet finalité oui mais la raison
pour laquelle je pense que ça touchera
pas nécessairement l'industrie du livre
je pense que l'industrie du livre a
encore sa place qui vaut l'avoir encore
longtemps c'est que l'expérience et par
là même si je suis consomme ta musique
avec un disque man rapide et écouteurs
et aucune différence entre ceux qui
écoutent et amusé quelqu'un iphone
pleugers sur son sur itunes puis dans
des écouteurs ça finit en exécutant les
oreilles tu consommes la musique de
façon structurelle album tu peux
l'écouter aussi sur sur spotify sur
itunes dans ce que le livre c'est pas la
même chose
les gueux l'expérience du véhicule je
comprends qu'elle ait lieu avant l'aube
les livres ça passe par un réseau de
distribution ça passe par des éditeurs
qui est sûr c'est que je pense pas que
ça va démocratiser la même façon pis là
sous questions à ce que je t'entends là
dessus c'est est ce que tu penses que
si ce que tu écris c'est bon
ça vaut pas son chemin non non pas
nécessairement non je pense que ça prend
un espèce d'alignement des baisers toile
dans une certaine direction pour être
publiée pour être lu je pense que tu es
comme un livre que du succès c'est pas
un gage 900 max est bon mais je pense
que tu es oui il ya plusieurs affaires
qui fait qu'un livre steve va
fonctionner ou vos pas fonctionné puis
mai puis un livre très bon peut ne pas
trouver son public aussi pour toutes
sortes de raisons qu'on comprend pop lui
aussi sait qu'à un moment donné
comme je dis y'a la masse ça se perd
dans la masse aussi sur qui est le très
bon au livre de fiction qui sort
peut-être que ça va donner une la même
semaine que et la biographie de céline
dion va sortir puis que l'on entend donc
non je pense que le fait que ce soit
populaire ou populaire c'est pas un gage
de deux talents ou de poche de pantalon
c'est ce qui me fait dire que c'est
difficile elle s'est en fait la
littérature c'est extrêmement difficile
type d autant moi j'ai eu la statistique
provins que toi tu contre lattes dans
les mémoires m'avait dit qu'il y avait
huit auteurs au québec où elles vivent
exclusivement de toi ça voulait pas dire
qu'ils vivent est exclusivement de dieu
ils pouvaient faire autre chose soucy
mis à la veille 8,8 le c'est pas
beaucoup le nombre de personnes qui
écrivent au québec lancé qui j'ai des
amis de vraiment grands talents que moi
je trouve que c'est une paire parce que
peut-être que si on était dans un autre
pays depuis leur lit il aurait pu se
trouver preneur petit à petit et moi des
fois lost un questionnement que j'ai sur
moi même dit que si je me dis si mettons
maintenant mais pourquoi toi ça marche
et je suis pas capable de te répondre
petit même des fois ça va mais c'est qui
c'est comme je sais pas qui j'étais
chanceuse puis piste comme je disais au
début c'était pas prévu et si j'avais
voulu faire quelque chose qui marche
j'aurais essayé de faire quelque chose
de fantastique avec un personnage de
goûter fac j'ai je me sens chanceuse que
je me sens fier de finalement que ça ait
fonctionné avec finalement l'idée que je
voulais faire mais je suis vraiment
reconnaissante puis à chaque fois que je
dis aux gens qui viennent me voir des
salons du livre ce leur dis tout le
temps merci puis j'ai vraiment j'ai
vraiment du plaisir à voir les gens
petit mais j'ai perdu la question
ce que je voulais dire c'est que des ya
beaucoup de monde qui peut vivre la
littérature dans ce cas à ce que j'ai
oublié pas s'en fait sentir mal à
l'université laval juin cours avec
dominique demers qui était légende vu la
littérature jeunesse mais le chargé de
cours à l'université laval
ici c'est fou le thé de penser à ce
qu'elle faisait peut-être pas le faisait
on peut dire sûrement pas par passion
pour le fun parce que c'était un cours
de littérature jeunesse d'écriture pour
la littérature jeunesse mais quand même
du parti
mettons justement encore je parle encore
de patrick mais patrick et il ya déjà
été prof de cinéma polonais arrêté parce
qu'il travaillait trop comme au top mais
l'autre jour on se parlait de bon
qu'est-ce que tu ferais 6 pts se
prononcer d'imaginer notre vie c'est
quoi notre plan b puis me disaient
qu'ils adorent enseigné puis que ce
serait limite même pas un plan des
lecteurs optiques et s'il s'en va quérir
commencé à six avait plus de temps à
enseigner par plaisir à enseigner les
cinémas dont le job avec moi des fois
c'est parce que des fois le quand et
auteur le titre seul j'ai été vraiment
tout seul des fois c'est ça peut être
lourd cette vie de solitaire le chi et
puis c'est ce qui fait que des fois tu
dia mais si je me trouve un petit
contrôle des êtres humains à qui des
fois ça peut même d'inspirer un
squelette un peu ta connaissance
transmet puis aussi à prendre contact
cassant le dos on apprend tellement à
chaque semaine sa l'audience mais oui
désolé ça fait six mois qu'on fait ce
petit i et j ai une énorme différence le
maintenant je parle en abris
conversation puis je me suis plus de
savoir qui fait qui est souple et la fin
parce qu'il jeta marche chaque semaine
on se demande des mondes variés puis
même si très cher mais avec ce que vous
dites est ce nom c'est vraiment parquet
enfin pepsi revenus mais tu sais pas si
j'ai pris mes skis ski est ce que je
trouve cool dans le processus aussi des
podcasts et contrex notre conversation
se poursuit de semaine en semaine et
avec nous deux on est là nous deux on a
une conversation avec naïveté
oui le thé comme la conversation sur
justement les objectifs puis comment
atteindre des objectifs après que
d'après des refus peut on s'en est parlé
à semaine passée le saccage de rigide
plus up en arrêt dans une discussion
ainsi c'est un tremplin pour en reparler
encore fixé mais ton j'ai une idée on
est innocent quelque chose mais les
mettons vraiment dans la recherche doit
faire pour le pôle invités ça va évoluer
dans la conversation c'est vrai concède
évoluer dans les jours après leurs
pensées leurs écouter le podcast a
continué voulu effectuer
c'est vraiment ça amène la pensée puis
la réflexion ça c'est même si ça te
c'est repos ce même si cette donne plein
emploi ou quelque chose de tangible ça
dans la vie le jeu de quitte d'être
quelqu'un qui connaît un petit peu plus
pleine affaire qui est et qui s'est dit
ce qu'ils quittent serge je suis dans
une relation humaine qui dans les choix
turf rapide soit effectué c'est vraiment
positif
j'avais une observation tantôt dans le
fond tu parles de patrick senécal au
québec vous devez être parmi les plus
ceux qui ont le mieux réussi dans le
domaine de la littérature en termes de
popularité et puis 2-2 public qui est
tout seul mais j'ai l'impression que
parle par le succès puis moelleux je
parle de du du background d'études
littéraires comme on parlait en début
qu'une espèce de jugement à voir la
popularité j'ai l'impression que lui
aussi est sujet à ce jugement là moi je
n'ai jamais vu pour patrick
non jamais non mais je pense que lui des
fois il me l'a déjà parce que parce que
je te je peux en témoigner avons entendu
des commentaires comme ceux par rapport
à la littérature populaire mais je pense
que lui oui c'est sûr que des fois le
roman de genre et je pense que il
pourrait dire que oui je pense que je
pense qu'ils m'ont déjà dit quelque
chose comme ceux en même temps le tire
le mieux à faire le tout s'est tu
continues à parce qu'on aime ce temps ou
si c'est de décider
pitié des fois oui c'est sûr que ça pue
m'affecter de de la perception qu'on
peut avoir deux mois ou deux ce que
j'écris qui
piloter on dirait que ce que tu veux
faire dans ce temps là c'est prouvé que
finalement bien regarde tchèque j'ai
gagné un prix en italie tchèque il ya
une super bonne critique dans le wall
street journal faculté comme cédric tu
voudrais 18 mois témoin des fois j'ai
des super bonne critique le jeu le
partage projet commun
tu piges avait parlé de tout justement
l'ism nadeau tu sais pas ce qu'elle
avait fait de cette vidéo le dérangeante
j avais dit que que oui c'est vrai
j'avais dit que des fois je me sentais
mal de publier certaines critiques parce
que j'ai tout le talent j'ai tout le
temps dans deux mois voilà tout qui
croient comme pauvre pantin non c'est
parce que c'est que je me dis je vois de
savoir l'art d'inventer qui je sais pas
comment promettre partagé fait qu'ils
jugent sans voir l'inventeur qu'un
chèque
justement tu dis qu'il y en a pas
beaucoup qui se fait et je me dis je
suis mieux de le rester lowepro faire
pitié comme si je dis les jambes ça va
peut-être les gossip ou c'est comme le
je me souviens il y ont sorti un
communiqué sur les chiffres de ventes du
dernier aurélie j'ai pas partager sur
les réseaux sociaux n'est pas partagé
sur les réseaux sociaux parce que
j'avais peur cd non les les
la maison d'édition émis un communiqué
les communautés sur sa sortie les chefs
d'oeuvre dans les journaux le ben moi
j'avais des alertes google c'est comme
quoi qu'ils avaient des articles de
journaux pour acheter le partage plus je
partage pas hier tu vois j'ai partagé
1-1 à un article de blog et d'une bonne
critique d'un de mes livres qui sortent
en anglais qui encore aujourd'hui
j'étais comme on s'arrête si comme je
suis vraiment c'est vraiment ambivalent
c'est quand je partage une bonne
critique le suppose truc qui me fait le
plus de like parce que je me dis c'est
pour ce que je me dis qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec souci on le partage sur le
partage du pot si je le partage bougez
vous de cherbourg l'air de pau t on
c'est comme toi avec ton couple si les
gens entendent parler de ton couple ils
savent poste est encore en couple faites
le si toi tu parles pas de et gpat été
éventé palmarès tout le monde y pense
plus que finalement tout ça pas marché
c'est le même qui sont 20 kg par rapport
à toi métier je me dis qu'en double les
jeunes découvriront par aux mêmes
joueurs ont partagé une fois de temps en
temps qui me touche métier je veux les
honda m'avait dit partage le ca donne
l'espoir s'est quittés encore le jus pas
encore réussi à toute femme et j'ai fait
un petit peu plus depuis quand même je
me permets un petit peu plus depuis
qu'un mot disons le clairement le
syndrome de l'imposteur tu habites
encore nous attendait dans une musique
et à chaque nouveau roman tout ça d'ici
celui le que les gens pas démasqués à
celui le rend compte que je t'ai que je
sais pas trop bien mais c'est incroyable
de penser ce qui après tout le succès
après tentant de lectrices
plus d'un million québec 2 millions en
france le jeu tu es incroyable de penser
ce que
quilles encore 1 2 1 2 du plan et si je
sais pas comment est ce que tu penses
moi je lève je l' ai vécu
d'être dans la marge de la marge s'était
tu étais dans la marge parce que tu
t'intéresses aux lettres fait est déjà
un artiste marginal mais que dans ce
titre connaît pas non plus oui
témoin le futur on se parle de tout et
de loin
tu es loin d'être l'archétype qu'on se
fait d'une hauteur de quelqu'un qui
attend les trois cpie de ce que tu me
décris de patrick senécal ça me semble
être la même chose ils rentrent pas dans
l'archétype de 2 comme l'elysée à l'être
secret potasser boutique ce même si trip
sur les coûts qu'ils diront pas mais est
ce que tu penses que ça pourrait
participer à l' espèce de sentiment de
ne pas être à ta place dans un milieu
qui est restrictif parce que moi je
trouve ça ultra fermé le jeu trouve que
le domaine des led l'espèce d'élitisme
autour de 6 des lots moi ça me fait pas
du tout pioneer annonce que je suis est
pas un en ce moment mon parcours à
l'université mais est ce que tu penses
que ça ça joue un peu un rôle un peu tu
es toi tu sais si c'est pas fou puis
- je sais pas si c'est comme deux des
témoignages je viens de québec puis
j'avais plein drive qui rêve
spitz et qui jamais j'aurais pu penser
qu'un jour j'aurai des livres publiés
que je me retrouverais dans une dans une
bibliothèque à côté des livres que
j'aime et puis je pense que on donne moi
comme encore tout le temps ce petit pays
le cac revient pas comme si je décroche
pas de ceux ya quelque part moi ce
serait ma plus grande peur un moment
donné de pu avoir de doute ça serait la
première fois le cas ok on en a donné le
jour raconté j'avais eu une bonne
critique dans la presse de sony à fait
ok c'était la première sortie d'aurélie
pss ça faisait attention succès à
l'horizon l'arctique était super bon sur
mes livres ce qui le je me suis sentie
poli
pis
jallet jalel bruncher avec ma famille je
me suis là je suis parti de saint-andré
marianne qu'il fallait que j'aille
jusqu'à mont royal de l'ovni hockey pis
le jeu flotter au début de ma marche
plus j'en revenais pas de toutes les
beaux mots que j'avais lu pitre ce club
je me souviens que j'ai fait non non
jamais je veux pas que je veux pas être
cette personne love qui flotte au dessus
de la terre je vois pu être moi même
j'aurais pu être mon essence je peux
être qui je m'étais force et toute la
marche à me ramener à tarbes cc comme
une image mais jeter comme je pu le
sentir le sentiment que je flotte
j'avais déjà raconté ça joue le jeu vous
invite au qui m'avait dit prendre le
temps de célébrer sa phrase mangue
d'epinal
parce que j'ai flotté par une journée
pas présent mais d'autres assez mais on
dirait que moi c'est c'est comme si ces
jeux mais jamais le des prix sur mes
murs jeu mais paul et les affiches de
film c'est comme si je veux tout à
recommencer à zéro comme retrouver le
sentiment de cas j'ai voulu écrire mon
premier livre je voulais dire quelque
chose je voulais les faire ce que je
voulais faire ce je veux pas mais je
vais pas m'asseoir sur mes succès je
veux pas je veux tout recommencer à zéro
puisque pour ce que je referai pas une
série qui ressemble à aurélie laflamme
si j'ai des affaires à dire avec aurélie
laflamme genre sortir une histoire de
temps en temps mais je ferai pas la même
affaire parce que ça marche et je ferai
pas parce que pour moi c'est important
de me mettre en danger d'essayer des
choses de mais oui le sentiment
d'imposture me quitte pas des fois ci
c'est du style aviv puis des fois ça
m'amène loin et le des fois ça m'amène
que quand une journée jeux pas capable
d'écrire je me cherche un job piste
sérieuse dans mes démarches
ouais je me cherche un job et puis je
vois sur des sites d'emploi
ouais je me dis j'ai peur
je sais mais je me cherche des jobs puis
je me demande qu'est ce que je pourrais
faire pour le moment donné le jeu mais
dont je clique sur un emploi petit à
petit le jeu mais je me mets à penser à
qu'est ce que ça serait travaillait au
tapis une idée imaginée par think i
reçoit ton cv ces camps et des jardins
je connaissais s'annonce haute en avril
à pourquoi qu'elle applique ici c'est
lorsqu'elle est en jeu c span traduit
déjà voulait appliquer à sceller le
polisseur dans les planchers métro pitre
antilles je regarde ces gens le qui je
me dis sion pas besoin de trouver une
idée le triptyque piste route c'est moi
je trouve que des folies c'est comme
satisfaisant que j'ai déjà voulu
appliquer pour polir les plus tôt mattel
femme pendant deux jours la salle est
trop d'idées j'avais une amie auteurs à
manille qui me dit que y était chargé le
chef cuisiner mais travailler en cuisine
ne te jeter le c'est clair que te
poignet ce job là pour écrire un roman
sur la vie en cuisine parce que ça aucun
rapport que ce que le travailleur accusa
aucun rapport des fois je pense que ça
fait partie aussi d'un cheminement
créatif ah oui tu râles ont déjà pu t'en
parle
oui mais les deux saisons que le doute
était temps est essentiel quand ça
disparaît apprécié que trouve que ce
sport mais des fois c'est toujours à vis
du cloud sûrement c'est bien ma fille et
mon chum ya une station moelleux que des
fois il travaille dans son bureau + moi
j'arrive et le gema doudou plus je me
couche c'est comme ça sur divers dans
son bureau puisque oui
c'est pourquoi j'ai souri je comprends
pas pourquoi j'ai voulu écrire ce roman
là j'ai pu déjà rives pas pu piloter
c'est un tout petit dit regarder ton
dont je peux commenter le dim et ont
gardé son coeur d'enfant un peu la
petite fille en toi type wii puis mais
ça aussi c'est ce qui fait ce qu'il fait
on succès une impression puisqu'il fait
que la fille dans sa thèse
non mais j'aime bouger aucun doute là
dessus on aimerait aussi lille
si autant de personnes qui sont reconnus
en toi c'est à cause de psys sa cause
que te pour tuer l'enfant toi oui ok à
12 ans déchu
je suis madame tout le monde c'est petit
si on veut tout laisse penser on pense
tout le temps des fois que c'est
justement qu'on est un extraterrestre
mais témoin ce que ça m'a aidé et
aurélie savoir que se sentir extrait ce
sentiment le plus humain du monde puis
comment je me sens bien finalement plein
d'autres personnes se sentent comme
seuls les livres pour moi c'est un peu
devenu un lien entre moi et les autres
un lien de pêche comme ceux aiment aussi
qu'il est finalement il ya d'autres
personnes qui sont comme ça donc
donc je suis pas capable de l'expliquer
les succès factice pour ce que je te dis
des images parce que je peux kg pas
capable de dire que ça vient vraiment de
moi ou plus d'un timing de view tous mes
2 mai de 68 extraterrestes de santé puis
je pense que je juge finalement comme
plusieurs personnes qui je suis la
garonne exige
je suis pas nécessairement le personnage
principal du film qui se démarque tout
parce que dans ma vie j'ai j'ai été une
ado qui qui mangeait tout seul dans une
toilette qui avait fait le serment les
meilleures notes à l'école que j'ai
poète et populaire à l'école que plein
de choses comme ça puis finalement mais
je m'en tire pas si pire dans ma vie si
je fais le travail que j'aime ça
fonctionne bien est bloqué mais merci
beaucoup merci pour cette conversation
là c'était vraiment ultra chic dessin
pur mais aussi beaucoup
[Musique]